GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE WE'RE GOING TO WE'LL
GET STARTED HERE DON'T KNOW
THAT THEY'LL BE A COUPLE OF
OTHER MEMBERS COME IN AND OUT
OF THE HEARING AT TODAY BUT I
WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE. TO
OUR FIRST INFORMATION HEARING
FOR THE ASSEMBLY WATER PARKS
AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE WE HAVE
A FULL AGENDA WITH SOME GREAT.
SPEAKERS A WILL BE INVITING US
TO SOME OF THE- ISSUES
CHALLENGES OPPORTUNITIES THAT
ARE BEFORE US AS IT RELATES TO
OUR STATE PARKS. OPPORTUNITIES
FOR INVESTMENTS AS WELL AS THE
COVER NINETEEN A PANDEMIC AND
ITS IMPACT ON- THE SERVICES AT
THE STATE PROVIDES I'M GOING TO
GO OVER. A FEW LOGISTICAL
THINGS AND THEN WE'LL GO OVER-
AND OFF WE HAVE TO DO A ROLL
CALL FORMALLY FOR INFORMATION
HEARINGS BUT I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE TO COLLEAGUES IN
THE LET THEM SAY A FEW WORDS.
ONCE WE GO OVER SOME OF THE
LOGISTICAL- HEARING. MATTERS
HERE SO I'D LIKE TO CONVENE THE
THIS COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US AS WELL AS THE
PALACE THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
WATCHING THE LIVE STREAM. AND
ANYONE CALLING IN LATER TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS. I
BEGAN BY SHARING A FEW NOTES
ABOUT THE LOGISTICS OF OUR
HEARING TODAY. THESE STEPS HAVE
BEEN TAKEN TO HELP PRESERVE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
AND ENSURE THE PUBLIC TAXES TO
THE SKY ISN'T. DUE TO THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE. IN THIS HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE. WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THIS
HEARING- IN PERSON. WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MUST BE WORN AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM. OR AT A
REMOTE VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE.
NOT HAVE AMASSED WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. MOST IF NOT ALL
OUR PANELISTS TODAY WILL BE
JOINING US REMOTELY SO PLEASE
BEAR WITH US IF WE NEED TO WORK
THROUGH SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES.
TODAY WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A
MINIMAL CONTAGION OF STAFF AND
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN POLICIES.
THERE ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE FOR
THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE
THE CAPITOL FOR THOSE HERE IN
THE ROOM AS WELL. IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO OFFER PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME PLEASE
YOUR HAND. AND I WILL ASK THAT
YOU APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
WOULD ALSO ASK THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCHED A MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU
ARE DONE TESTIFYING. OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING. ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
FOR DIAL IN. WE WILL BE USING
HE MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. THE CALL
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING. IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE. ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS
WELL AS ON THE WEBCAST HEARING
HERE. THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE
WILL GIVE YU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE.
TO SPEAK AT ALL APPROPRIATE
TIME. CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST ANDYOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
ISSUES. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN ALSO CALL
OUR COMMITTEE AND A MEMBER OF
OUR TEAM AT 916-319-2096 I WILL
BE THERE TO BE OF ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US
AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO KEEP
AND CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO
BEING MINDFUL RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. THE TO ANOTHER HEARING IN
THIS ROOM LATER WE WILL NEED TO
CONCLUDE THE HEARING AT EXACTLY
TWELVE PM I WILL DO MY BEST TO
KEEP THINGS MOVING AND BASS
THAT MY COLLEAGUES ASSIST ME
WITH THAT EFFORT- WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO JUST ASK OF MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ALL START RIGHT
HERE BELOW. THEY WANT JUST US A
FEW WORDS AND THOUGHT THEY WILL
BRING BACK- IN THIS DIRECTION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AS OUR
FIRST WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE AND LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR PUTTING THIS ON AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE PRESENTATION
FROM THREE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AFTERWARDS. THANK YOU.
SOME. CAN YOU HEAR ME. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN- I WOULD ECHO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STUFFS SMITH
THE SAME THING I'M EXCITED TO
BE ON THERE I THINK CARP. OR
PARKS ESPECIALLY NOW ESPECIALLY
WITH ALL THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE GOING THROUGH- OR SEEN
OUR PARKS BEING UTILIZED MORE
MORE EVERY DAY SO. IT IS AN
IMPORTANT FACTOR- FOR ALL OF US
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
I KNOW IT'S PARTY FOR-
ESPECIALLY IN OUR DISTRICT- YOU
KNOW THAT THAT STUFF WE DO THE-
WHATEVER WE CAN. TO PROTECT
THEM AND- KEEP THEM SAFER FOR
OUR COMMUNITY SO THANK YOU MR.
REVENUES IN Q. FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND I APPRECIATE
THE FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CERTAINLY BEEN
WORKING ON IN TERMS OF CREATING
GREATER ACCESS WITH YOUR
SUPPORT OF COURSE MISTER CHAIR
OF THE LAST FEW YEARS AND I
THINK THAT THE COVERT PANDEMIC
IS FURTHER EXEMPLIFIED THE NEED
NOT ONLY FOR ALL OF US FOR OUR
OWN PUBLIC HEALTH AND WELL
BEING- TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
OUTDOORS TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
EQUITABLE AND SO I APPRECIATE-
THAT THE TOPICS ARE REALLY HERE
FROM TODAY AND IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU HAVE. A GREAT SLATE OF
BOXER GONNA HELP BETTER INFORM
US AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION SO THANK
MEASURE TO. MEASURE GOOD
MORNING. I'M INTERESTED HERE
THE PRESENTATION TODAY- MUCH OF
MY DISTRICT WAS IMPACTED WHEN
PEOPLE WERE COMING AT NORTH
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND SO ARE
PARKS AND WERE MET WITH A LOT
OF CHALLENGES- SO I'M ANXIOUS
TO HEAR IF THERE'S SOLUTIONS
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN THE
FUTURE BECAUSE PEOPLE DO WANT
TO BE OUTSIDE AND THEY DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO OUR PUBLIC
SPACES AND THEY SHOULD IN A
SAFE WAY BUT WE ALSO CAN'T BE
HARMING OUR ENVIRONMENT. AND-
SO WE'VE REALLY THERE'S BEEN
MUCH CHALLENGES WITH THE
DUMPING AND ILLEGAL CAMPING IN
MY DISTRICT DURING THE LAST FEW
MONTHS SO THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO THE PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
MEANT CHAIR SO AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER WE'RE GOING TO BE-
DIVING INTO YOU KNOW THE
CHALLENGES THAT OUR PARKS AND
OPEN SPACES HAVE SEEN DURING
THIS COVERT NINETEEN AND- AND
PERHAPS SOME WOULD SAY EVEN
BEFORE THAT. AS IT RELATES TO
ACCESS AND- MAINTENANCE AND
THINGS OF THAT SORT. SO WHILE
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO.
HEARING FROM OUR PANELISTS
THERE. WE ALSO AE GOING TO
HEAR ABOUT SOME OF THE SUCCESS
STORIES WE'VE HAD SOME-
INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE
ABOUT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
DUE TO THE PASSING OF PROP
SIXTY EIGHT. WE ALSO WANT TO
HEAR ABOUT THAT RIGHT IT IS AND
ALWAYS ALL. BAD WE HAVE SOME
GOOD THINGS HAPPENING. AS A
RESULT OF POLICY INVESTMENTS
THAT THE STATE HAS MADE. BUT
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
HOW THE LEGISLATURE CAN ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS. HAVE AND
ARE ABLE TO ENJOY OUR BEAUTIFUL
PARKS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SAFE- MANNER. IN
WHICH- WE ALL WANT TO MAKE SURE
OF. OUR CONSTITUENTS- ARE AND-
SO WITH THAT- WE WILL BEGIN
WITH OUR SPEAKERS WE HAVE THREE
PANELS SPEAKERS. I ASKED SAID
WE HEAR THE PRESENTATIONS
BEFORE WE GET INTO QUESTIONS.
AFTER THE PANELS. WILL FEATURE
PRESENTATIONS OF. WITHOUT THAN
GOING TO A WELCOME. OUR FIRST
THE GROUP AND THE FIRST PERSON
THAT WILL BE SPEAKING AS OF
MONDAY IN FEDERAL DIRECTOR. OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION. FOLLOW BY
STAFFORD LEADER. WHO IS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WILDLIFE AND
FISHERIES DIVISION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE. AND NORMA EITHER
GARCIA GONZALEZ DIRECTOR OF.
KIND OF LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT.
OF PARKS AND RECREATION
FOLLOWED BY NOW SHE RUNS ANY. A
PHD M. P. MD M. P. H. R.
EPIDEMIOLOGIST I WILL BE.
SPEAKING TO US AS WELL SO. I
WILL GO AHEAD AND START WITH
THE FIRST PRESENTER DIRECTOR
CAN BETTER WELCOME. AND THAT
CONGRATULATIONS FOR YOUR NEW
APPOINTMENT WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR PRINT
ASIAN A WORKING. WITH THE-
PROJECTS. A GOOD MORNING MISS
CHAIRMAN. OF THE NEXT. PLEASURE
YOUR YOU. I AM A MOM LOOKING
THAT- THE DIRECT OF DEPARTMENT
AND REC. AND I VERY MUCH YOU
FOR THE INVITATION TO
PARTICIPATE IN EXPERIENCE. YOU
KNOW AS WE EXPERIENCE THIS
WORLD THAT IS CHANGING SO
RAPIDLY BEFORE IT. I WANT TO
REMIND US THAT THE FIRST PUBLIC
LAND SET ASIDE IN CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY SATISFIED IN EIGHTEEN
SIXTY OR NOT WAS YOU SOMEBODY.
THE LAST TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY YEARS. WE'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN CARRYING FORWARD BEACH
TRADITIONS. AND CERTAINLY IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS WE'RE SEEING
THAT THE CHRISTIAN TRADITIONS
THAT WE- PART IN TERMS OF LAND
MANAGEMENT HAVE NOT BEEN SERVED.
SO CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS IS
LOOKING AT BRINGING TOGETHER
THE BEST WHAT IS THE- WE NEED
ORGANIZATION WITH OUR PART
PARTNERS AND WITH THE PUBLIC AT
LARGE WE NEED THE BEST WITH
THEM. CONSTABLE AS WE MANAGE
AND REBUILD THE PARKS AND AS WE
CREATE PARKS FOR THE FUTURE. SO
I AM COMMITTING THAT WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE DOING AND WHAT
WE ARE AND HAVE BEEN. IS A
POINT THE BEST KNOWLEDGE IN
SCIENCE THAT INCLUDES. ACTIONS
AND DECISIONS THAT ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE. PRACTICES OF
EQUITY AND INCLUSION. CAPTION
OF CULTURAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES THE ENHANCEMENT OF
BIODIVERSITY AND HABITATS IN
THESE PUBLIC LANDS AND THE
LANDS THAT ARE ADJACENT TO
PARKS BY WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS. AND WE'RE WE ARE
GOING TO BE FOCUSING OR
CONTINUING TO FOCUS ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW PARK LEADERS
FOR THIS CENTURY. GOING FORWARD
WE ACTUALLY ARE IN A MOMENT
WHERE WE ARE GOING TO BE
DEVELOPING THE TRADITIONS FOR
THE NEXT HUNDRED YEARS AND SO
WE'RE EXTRAORDINARILY EXCITED
ABOUT WORKING WITH THE
COLLECTIVE. IN APPROACHING THAT
GOAL. THE WORK DONE BY
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS STAFF
PARK STAKEHOLDERS- ALONG WITH
THE PARKS FORWARD IN
TRANSFORMATION CHANGE OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS. HAS SET A
REALLY INCREDIBLE POSITIVE
TRAJECTORY FOR THIS DEPARTMENT
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THAT MOMENTUM.
PERSONALLY I HAVE BEEN A
LIFELONG STUDENT OF THE NATURAL
WORLD AND ACTUALLY OF HISTORY.
I AM A STUDENT OF STATE
NATIONAL PARKS AND PUBLIC LANDS
AND AS AN ADULT I'VE
CONTINUALLY ENGAGE WITH PUBLIC
LANDS IS A PARK RANGER. AS A
PERSONNEL SPECIALIST IN PARKS
VOLUNTEER IS A SCIENCE
PROFESSIONAL FUNDRAISER
RESOURCES MANAGER I'VE WORKED
AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL. I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN AN AVID PARK
VISITOR A FULL TIME DAD FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME AND MORE. I LOVE
PARKS I LOVE PUBLIC LANDS AND
THE WATERS OF THIS STATE
ANNALYNNE ALONG OUR COAST. MY
WIFE AND I REYES OUR DAUGHTERS
EXPLORING THESE PARKS AND
EXPLORING THE PLANET AS MUCH AS
WE COULD. OUR DAUGHTERS AND I'M
VERY PROUD TO SAY REFER TO
THEMSELVES AS CITIZENS OF THE
WORLD. THERE COULD BE NO
GREATER PRIVILEGE IN MY LIFE
THAN TO SERVE YOU YEAH OUTDOORS
IN THE PUBLIC. I DO HAVE TO SAY
THAT- ON STEPPING INTO THIS
ROLE ON SEPTEMBER FIRST IT WAS
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PANDEMIC.
THERE WERE TWENTY TWO PARTS
THAT WERE ON FIRE MOST OF
CALIFORNIA WAS ON FIRE. AND AS
YOU KNOW PRIOR TO THIS YEAR THE
AVERAGE ACRES THAT BURNED IN
CALIFORNIA IN A FIRE YEAR WAS
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES. THIS YEAR WE SAW OVER
FOUR AND A HALF MILLION ACRES
BURNED IN OUR WILDLIFE. AND THE
EXTRAORDINARY THING. IS THAT
THIS YEAR THE FIRE SEASON
RATHER THAN ENDING IN NOVEMBER
AS MANY OF YOU ARE AWARE
ACTUALLY CONTINUED RIGHT
THROUGH DECEMBER WE ARE LIVING
IN A VERY ACTIVE TIME OF SEEN
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
SO AT THE HEART OF WHAT WE DO
WE'RE GOING TO BE FOCUSED ON
ALL OF THAT WHICH AS WE KNOW
THIS YEAR WHAT WE SAW WAS AN
EXTRAORDINARY INCREASE IN
VISITOR SHIPPED TO ALL THE
PUBLIC LANDS. MANY OF THE
COMPLAINTS ARE. UP TO TWO TIMES
THE VISITATION THAT WE'VE EVER
HAD IN THE PAST AND I THINK
VERY IMPORTANTLY. I'D LIKE TO
KNOW THAT WHAT HAPPENED DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. IS IT BECAME
CLEAR THAT THESE PUBLIC LANDS
AND PARKS ARE IN CENTRAL
LANDSCAPES. THEY'RE ESSENTIAL
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH. FOUR THE
CALL HEALTH OR MENTAL HEALTH. I
MIGHT EVEN SAY FOR SPIRITUAL
HELP AND FOR SOCIAL SOCIAL
HEALTH. OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
BETTER OFF BECAUSE OF THE PARKS
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO SO AS A
TEAM WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS
AND STAKEHOLDERS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE PLACES WHERE
THEY CAN GO. NEARBY AND FAR
AWAY TO HELP RESTORE YOUR
PHYSICAL MENTAL AND SOCIAL
HEALTH WE NEED MORE THAN EVER
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
STRENGTHENING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS ALONG WITH THE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
CERTAINLY WITH OUR PARTNERS AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS TIME.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR THERE WILL
GO ON TO THE NEXT SPEAKER ON
THE AGENDA- DIRECTOR- OH WELL.
FIGHT LIFE AND FISHERIES
DIVISION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT. OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE- STAFFORD LAYER
PLEASE. REPLY YOURS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- STAFFORD LATER ON
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF WILDLIFE
AND FISHERIES DIVISION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE. SO I KIND OF JUST
ONE OF. EXPRESS MY TESTIMONY
THAT WE ARE ON THE SERIES OF
EVENTS AND ACTIVITIES THAT WE
HAD- EXPERIENCED ACROSS THE
LANDSCAPE OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
MANAGEMENT JOB
RESPONSIBILITIES- IN EARLY
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY- THE
FISH AND WILDLIFE WE FORMED AN
INTERNAL CODE OF THE TASK FORCE
LIVE AT THE STATE HOME ORDERS.
WE BEGAN TO IMPLEMENT IT-
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY PLUS
PERCENT OF OUR WORKFORCE UNDER
TELEWORK CONDITIONS MISSION
CRITICAL AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
STAFF REMAINED WORKING IN THE
FIELD UNDER CODE SAFETY
PROTOCOLS AND GUIDELINES. WITH
THE STATE HOME ORDERS THAT
BEGAN TO ARISE IN MARCH AND
APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY. WE MEET
IMMEDIATELY BEGAN GETTING
QUESTIONS FROM THE PUBLIC
WHETHER IT'S OKAY TO GO FISHING
WAS IT OKAY TO GO OUTSIDE AND
RECORD. MANY PORTS AND HARBORS
AND OTHER PUBLIC ACCESS
LOCATIONS WERE CLOSED BY COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS AND WE
WERE WE WERE REFERRED AND
EXPRESSED TO THE PUBLIC THAT
THEY NEED TO DO IT HERE THOSE
LOCAL ORDERS AND ORDINANCES. IN
MID TO LATE MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY WE ALSO BEGAN TO HEAR
CONCERNS ABOUT LARGE FISHING
TOURNAMENTS THESE TOURNAMENTS
WERE LOCATED IN RURAL COUNTIES
WHEN THERE WAS CONCERN ABOUT
PARTICIPANTS TRAVELING GREAT
DISTANCES OFTEN EXCEEDING A
HUNDRED PLUS MILES AND BRINGING
COVE IT TO THEIR COUNTIES WHERE
THERE WERE LOWER INCIDENCE OF.
POSITIVITY WE NOTIFIED
TOURNAMENT ORGANIZERS TO
PLEASE- VOLUNTARILY POSTPONE OR
CANCEL THESE EVENTS. TO A LATER
DATE WHEN KOBE CONCERNS WERE
LESSEN WE HAD NO IDEA WHEN
THOSE CONCERNS WOULD BE LASSEN-
LATER IN MARCH AND EARLY APRIL
THE DEPARTMENT ALONG WITH FISH
AND GAME COMMISSION. WERE
APPROACHED BY ESIGHT SIERRA
COUNTIES. SIERRA NEVADA COUNTY
IS THAT WITH CONCERNS ABOUT THE
UPCOMING TROUT FISHING OCHRE.
AND THIS EVENT OCCURS AT THE
END OF APRIL. INTERNET OFTEN
BRINGS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
VISITORS TO THESE RURAL
COUNTIES AND THEY- AT THE END
OF THIS CALL FISH MASS AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DEAL
WITH A LARGE PUBLIC CAL SURGE
AND STRESSED THEIR LOCAL HEALTH
CARE- OPERATIONS. SO THEY
REQUESTED THAT WE POSTPONE THE
FISHING SEASON OPENER WE WORKED
WITH THE FISHING GAME
COMMISSION THE COMMISSION GAVE
THE DIRECTOR DELEGATED
AUTHORITY TO WORK WITH THE
COUNTY- OFFICIALS AND UPON A-
RICK FORMAL REQUEST BY THE
COUNTIES- THE DIRECTOR COULD
POSTPONE OR OR DELAYED THE
FISHING OPENER. AND THAT HAD A
SUNSET DATE MAY THIRTY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY. AND EVENTUALLY-
FISHING WAS DELAYED- IN ALPINE
MONO IN YOU KNOW AND SIERRA
COUNTIES AND I MUST SAY THESE
COUNTIES RELY VERY HEAVILY UPON
THE RECREATIONAL- THE ECONOMY
TO- SUPPORT THERE- COUNTY
BUDGETS AND ACTIVITIES SO IT
WAS A BIG ECONOMIC IT. TO THOSE
COUNTIES TO- TAKE THAT STEP AND
ASK FOR A DELAY. AS OF JUNE
FIRST ALL THESE COUNTY SAID
READ OPEN FISHING. REQUIREMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE OWNS AND
MANAGES OVER SEVEN HUNDRED PLUS
PROPERTIES EXCEEDING OVER ONE
POINT ONE BILLION ACRES ACROSS
THE STATE FOR WILDLIFE AND
HABITAT VALUES. PUBLIC VISITS
TO STATE OWNED WILDLIFE AREAS
AND ECOLOGICAL RESERVES
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY AS THE
PUBLIC SOUGHT PERSONAL RELIEF
FROM THE STAND HOMEWARDS
RECREATIONAL USES FROM HUNTING
FISHING HIKING BOATING AND
OTHER USES PUT MORE PEOPLE OUT
IN OPEN AREAS AND WE HAVE EVER
SEEN BEFORE. HUNTING AND
FISHING LICENSE SALES WERE UP
APPROXIMATELY 10% FROM PREVIOUS
YEARS. DUE TO THE INCREASE OF
PEOPLE SEEKING RECREATIONAL
OUTLETS FROM BEING COOPED UP AT
HOME. CONCURRENT WITH THIS
INCREASE IN PUBLIC USE OF OPEN
SPACE AND WILDLANDS WE HAVEN'T
SEEN AN INCREASE IN HUMAN
WILDLIFE CONFLICTS. IN OPEN
SPACES IN IN THE URBAN WILDLAND
INTERFACE WE HAVE OVER SIXTY
FIVE HUNDRED CONFLICTS ANNUALLY
AND WE HAVE SEEN AN UPTICK IN
WILDLIFE ATTACKS ON PEOPLE AS
THERE ARE MORE PEOPLE OUT NO
OPEN SPACES AND COMING INTO
CONTACT WITH LOT MORE WILDLIFE.
NOW PIVOTING AFTER THE SUMMER
OF ALL OF THIS GOING ON. LATE
AUGUST AND EARLY SEPTEMBER THE
STATE IS- DIRECTOR CAN TERO-
MENTIONED. WE EXPERIENCE THE
GREATEST WILDFIRE DISASTER IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY OVER FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION ACRES BURNED.
THE U. S. FOREST SERVICE AND
OTHER FEDERAL AGENCIES AND SOME
OF THE STATE'S LARGEST PRIVATE
TIMBERLAND OWNERS CLOSED THEIR
LANDS TO PUBLIC USE. IN TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF ADDITIONAL
WILDFIRES AND THEREBY STRESSING
AN ALREADY OVERTAXED FIRE
RESPONSE NETWORK. BERMAN CAN
CURRENTLY CLOSE FIFTEEN
WILDLIFE AREAS AND ECOLOGICAL
RESERVES THAT WERE WITHIN OR
IMMEDIATELY ADJACENT TO THESE
LARGE AREAS OF HIGH AND EXTREME
WILDFIRE RISKS. THESE CLOSURES
OCCURRED JUST AS MANY OF THE
MOST ICONIC HUNTING SEASONS
WERE BEGINNING TO TAKE PLACE.
ROCKSON ONLY FOURTEEN DIFFERENT
HUD SON THAT THE PUBLIC LOST
ALL OR A MAJORITY OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTAKE IN THAT
ACTIVITY MANY OF THESE SITES
COST HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS IN TAG
THESE AND SOME MEMBERS HAD
WAITED OVER TWENTY YEARS TO
BUILD UP ENOUGH PREFERENCE
POINTS TO BE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY- HOW THE
COMPETITIVE DRAW. THE
DEPARTMENT WORKS WITH THE FISH
AND GAME COMMISSION TO REFUND
TAG FEES AND RESTORE THEIR
PREFERENCE POINTS SO THEY WOULD
HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY AT
SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE TO
PARTAKE IN THIS ONCE IN A
LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY. PIVOTING
TO THE LATER FALL. IN LATE
OCTOBER AND EARLY NOVEMBER THE
WATERFOWL HUNTING SEASON ARE
PRESENTED NEIGHBORHOOD MAJOR
CHALLENGES AS HUNTERS DESCENDED
UPON STATE AND FEDERAL REFUGES.
AND THE DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEE
CONTACT LIST- CHECK INS AN
EMPLOYEE CODE SAFETY PROTOCOLS
AND GUIDELINES TO ENSURE STOP
AND PUBLIC SAFETY AS THEY WERE
PARTAKING IN THESE ACTIVITIES.
WITH THE TREMENDOUS SURGEON
CODE CASES DRING THIS TIME IN
NEW STAY AT HOME ORDERS THAT
INCLUDED RESTRICTIONS ON PUBLIC
CAMPING. MANY OF OUR AREAS WE
HAD TO CLOSE WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS- THE PUBLIC FROM CAMPING
ON THESE WILDLIFE AREAS. WE
ALSO RESTRUCTURED IN RESTRICTED
OUR HOURS OF OPERATION. THIS
RESULTED IN LONG LINES OF THE
PUBLIC HARD ON PUBLIC ROADWAYS
WAITING TO ENTER THESE PUBLIC
HUNTING AREAS AT VERY EARLY
HOURS IN THE MORNING OFTEN
UNDER VERY FOGGY CONDITIONS
YEAH PRESENTED A PUBLIC SAFETY
THREAT ON THE HIGHWAY. OVERALL
WE'VE SEEN A TREMENDOUS UPTICK
IN RECREATIONAL USE OF PUBLIC
LANDS THIS PAST YEAR AND IT'S
RESULTED IN AN INCREASE IN
TRASH AND STRESSED SANITATION
FACILITIES ON STATE PROPERTIES.
THIS IS HIGHLIGHTED A EED FOR
INCREASED PUBLIC AMENITIES AND
APPROPRIATE SIGNAGE THAT
CREATES A WELCOMING ENVIRONMENT
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
IN AREAS SURROUNDING URBAN
AREAS. IT WAS A VERY VERY BUSY
YEAR AND WE'RE PROUD TO OF MET
THE CHALLENGES TO PROVIDE A
SAFE AND HEALTHY RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA'S AND I THINK YOU
AND I'LL TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU DIRECTOR GOING TO
HOLD OFF ON THE QUESTION STILL
AFTER ALL THE PANELISTS ON THIS
FIRST- SEGMENT BUT THANK YOU
FOR THAT INSIGHT- THAT YOU'VE
PROVIDED WILL WANT TO OUR NEXT
A- SPEAKER OR PANELIST IS.
NORMA IF YOU'D GARCIA GONZALEZ
DIRECTOR OF COUNTY LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION AND THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY REGIONAL PARKS AND OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT. WELCOME- NORMA.
GOOD MORNING AND YOU ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE FOR HAVING YOU SPEAK
TODAY IT IS MY DISTINCT HONOR
TO SHARE WITH YOU THE CRITICAL
ROLE THAT PARK CITY LADY TO
PROVIDE RESPITE. PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING TO LOS
ANGELES COUNTY RESIDENTS. BUT
SPECIFICALLY TO ARE VULNERABLE
FAMILIES WHO HAVE BEEN HARDEST
HIT BY IMPACT A BY COBIT. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PARKS AND
RECREATION IS ONE OF THE MOST
DYNAMIC PARK SYSTEMS IN THE
STATE IF NOT THE NATION.
PROVIDING TEN MILLION COUNTY
RESIDENTS WITH REGIONAL PARKS
TRAILS LAKES. NATURAL AREAS
WILDLIFE SANCTUARIES AND GOLF
COURSES BOTANICAL GARDENS. THE
QUESTION CENTERS AND MUCH MORE.
WE ALSO PROVIDE LOCAL
RECREATION PROGRAMMING AND
SERVICES TO OVER ONE MILLION.
UNINCORPORATED RESIDENTS WHICH
INCLUDE COMMUNITY CENTERS
SENIOR CENTERS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE SPORT
COURTS AND FIELDS. AND HUNDREDS
OF PLAYGROUNDS NOT TO MENTION
OUR VAST PUBLIC RESTROOM
SYSTEM. Y. LAS ANIMAS COUNTY
PARK SYSTEM RECEIVES MORE THAN
FIFTEEN MILLION VISITS ON AN
AVERAGE YEAR. DURING COLD AND
WE EXCEEDED AVERAGE ATTENDANCE
VISITS. JOINT COLBERT MANY
SECTORS PARKS NEVER CLOSE ITS
DOORS ARE PARKS WE NEED OPEN TO
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SAFETY NET
SERVICES LIKE FOOD
DISTRIBUTIONS WE CONTINUE TO
OPPORTUNITY FOOD DISTRIBUTIONS
A WEEK. LEADING EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED TO TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
HOUSEHOLDS EVERY TIME. FORTY
POUNDS OF FOOD ENOUGH TO FEED A
FAMILY OF FOUR FOR A WEEK.
ARGENIS WE TRANSFORMED INTO
HOMELESS SHELTERS AND WENT TO
ADMITTED SHELTERS DURING
INCLEMENT WEATHER OUR PARKS
WORK TRUSTED VOTING CENTRES.
TRUSTED COBIT FIVE FIVE TESTING
SITES IN VACCINATION SITES IN
THE HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES. WE
PROVIDED CHILDCARE FOR
ESSENTIAL WONDERFUL WORKERS WHO
COULD NOT TELL THE WORK AND
WHILE SCHOOLS WERE ONLINE WE
PIVOTED TO PROVIDE TO PROVIDE A
SAFE OUTDOOR PROGRAMMING FOR
YOUTH AND TEENS. AND OUR PARK
SERVED AS EMERGENCY COMMAND
CENTERS THE WHAT OUR WATER IN
OUR LAKES IS DROPS FOR THE
BOBCAT FIRED AND THE MANY OTHER
FIRES IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN
TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY TWENTY
HAS GIVEN A NEW MEETING. TO
PARKS MAKE LIFE BETTER. IN
TWENTY SIX THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION COMPLETED
A COUNTY WIDE PARK NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. AND I'M PRESIDENT
EFFORT TO DOCUMENT CRITICAL
NEEDS IN CITIES AND
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. WILL NOT
FROM THE PARK NEEDS ASSESSMENT
AND I'M NOT ALL COMMUNITIES
HAVE EQUITABLE ACCESS. TO STATE
WELL MAINTAINED AND PROGRAM
PARKS AND GREEN SPACE. PARKS
ARE POISED TO EFFECTUATE EQUITY
AT A NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL
IMPACTING CLIMATE CHANGE HEALTH
AND EDUCATION OUTCOMES. BY
PRIORITIZING AND ADDRESSING
PARKING NEEDS IN COMMUNITIES WE
ARE DIRECTLY TACKLING RACIAL
INEQUITIES. AND LET ME BE CLEAR
THERE IS NO RACIAL JUSTICE
WITHOUT PARK EQUITY. RECENTLY
THE PREVENTION INSTITUTE AND
NATIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH
ORGANIZATION ALONG WITH UCLA
AND THE ROBERT WOOD JOHNSON
FOUNDATION PUBLISHED RESEARCH
LINKING THE LACK OF GREEN SPACE
WITH LIFE EXPECTANCY. USING OUR
PARKING NEEDS ASSESSMENT AS THE
BASIS OF THEIR RESEARCH THE
STUDY FOUND IF ALL OF THE
CENSUS TRACT IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WITH PART DEFICIT AND
LOW TREE CANOPY LEVELS. HAD AN
INCREASE IN PARK ACREAGE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND YEARS IN
LIFE EXPECTANCY COULD BE
GAINES. TARGETING INVESTMENTS
IN PARK INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY BENEFIT THE
HEALTH OF LATINO AND BLACK
RESIDENTS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY PARKS AND
RECREATION WITH OUR MANY
PARTNERS WILL BE TAKING A
CLOSER LOOK AT OUR RURAL AND
REGIONAL AREAS OF COUNTY TO
INCORPORATE INTO THE PARK NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. WE ARE CALLING TO
SEPARATE THE REGIONAL AND RURAL
ADDITION KIND OF TIMING
COULDN'T BE BETTER. WITH
BIDEN'S NEW EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
PROTECT 30% OF US LANDS AND 30%
OF US OCEANS BY TWENTY THIRTY.
AND THE GOVERNOR NEW SUMS
PLEDGE TO CONSERVE 30% OF
LANDING COASTAL WATERS ALSO BY
TWENTY THIRTY IN CALIFORNIA TO
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE AND
CONSERVE BIODIVERSITY AND BOOST
CLIMATE RESILIENCE. LOS ANGELES
COUNTY REGIONAL RULE ADDITION
WILL ENSURE THAT THIS COUNTY IS
ALIGNED WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
PRESIDENTIAL INITIATIVES VISIT
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFYING GAPS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LAND
ACQUISITION AND AREAS WERE
FINDING SHOULD. BE PRIORITIZED
ARE FOCUSED. CITI BANK FAMILY
THROUGH THE PLAN OUR MINIATURE.
ON OLD WASTELAND WITH POSITIVE
RESULTS FOR BIODIVERSITY AND
CARBON CAPTURE MANY OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PORT PART PORT
COMMUNITIES ARE ALSO REAT FOR.
THE LOT THE LACK OF TREES IN
THESE AREAS IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
HEALTH AND WELLNESS ISSUE AS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS BECAUSE OF
THEIR ZIP CODE. I'M ABLE TO
EXPERIENCE THE MANY BENEFITS OF
TREES. CALIFORNIA CLIMATE BOND
SHOULD SUPPORT THE STRATEGIC
PLANTING OF TREES IN URBAN
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY ARE
MOSTLY NEEDED AND TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE CONTEXT WHERE
TREES ARE PROPOSED. TO BE
PLANTED AND NOT JUST THE
OVERALL NUMBER OF TREES.
CLIMATE RESILIENCE MUST ALSO
INCLUDE HUMAN AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE THE PARKING
RECREATION SECTOR OFFER A WIDE
VARIETY OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES SPECIFICALLY FOR
AT RISK YOUTH. A GOOD EXAMPLE
IN L. A. COUNTY IS OF OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CONSERVATION COURSE TO PROVIDE.
ON THE JOB TRAINING FOR AT RISK
YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS LAST
YEAR MY DEPARTMENT HIRED
FOURTEEN YOUNG ADULTS FROM THE
CONSERVATION COURSE MANY OF
THEM SYSTEMS INVOLVES YOU. TO
WORK AS FULL TIME GROUNDS
MAINTENANCE AND LANDSCAPING
STAFF AND ON A SIDE NOTE. WITH
JOBS NEW JOBS BEING SO SCARED
BECAUSE OF KOBE ON APRIL FIRST
I WILL BRING ON THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE OF ALL YOU. TO
WORK AT OUR PARKS. AS PART OF A
YOUTH THAT WORK INITIATIVE.
STATE BONDS SHOULD CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT JOB CREATION AND
BONNEVAL COMMUNITIES. AND
INCENTIVIZE LIVING WAGE JOBS
AND TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOU. ACCORDING TO RECENT
ESTIMATES CALIFORNIA HAS OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND TWELVE THOUSAND
BROWNFIELD SITES. THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BROWNFIELD SITES
ARE STARK PHYSICAL EVIDENCE OF
UNRESOLVED ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ISSUES FACING
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
NEIGHBORHOODS HOWEVER NEW
INVESTMENTS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE BOND CAN'T PROVIDE
TRANSFORMATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
TO SUPPORT GREEN HEALTHY AND
ECONOMICALLY VIBRANT
COMMUNITIES. WHILE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IS KNOWN AS AN URBANIZED
AREA IT IS ACTUALLY PART OF A
BIODIVERSITY HOTSPOT CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA FLORISTIC PROPONENTS
WHICH IS THE PRETTIEST COUNTY
IN THE COUNTRY WITH MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED RECORDED SPECIES.
AND SITS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
FOUR THOUSAND MILE BIRD
MIGRATION FLYWAY THAT IS USED
BY AT LEAST A BILLION BIRDS
ANNUALLY. BIODIVERSITY AND
ECOLOGICAL HEALTH ARE PROMOTED
BY THE COUNTY'S MANY PARKS
INCLUDING LOCAL PARKS IN URBAN
COMMUNITIES STATE FUNDING
PROGRAMS SHOULD RECOGNIZE AND
SUPPORT FROM POINT ROLE THAT
URBAN PARKS PLAY IN CONSERVING
AND ENHANCING BIODIVERSITY
THEREBY HELPING TO MITIGATE AND
ADAPT TO THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. LASTLY I WANT TO SHARE
A STATE BOND FUNDING STATE BOND
FUNDING AT WORK. WHAT WE WANNA
PARK POCKET PARKS IS A HALF OF
MY HAPPENED A BIT IN SIZE AND
IS MUCH NEEDED IN A VERY HIGH
NEED PARK COMMUNITY WITH OVER
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND RESIDENTS
AND OVER FOUR THOUSAND YOU. AND
ALTHOUGH ITS NAME IS ONE OF
PARK THERE IS NO CURRENT PARK
IN THIS COMMUNITY AND YOU CAN
VISUALLY SEE THE DENSITY IN THE
SOUTHEAST COMMUNITY IN THE
MATERIALS THAT I PROVIDED TO
YOU. THE CREATION OF THIS NEW
PARK WILL HELP TO ADDRESS. I'M
BY HELP TO ADDRESS THE PART
DENSITY BY INSTALLING A MICHAEL
FORREST A THIRTY EIGHT DROUGHT
TOLERANT NATIVE TREES ON A SITE
THAT HAS BEEN VACANT FOR OVER
TWO DECADES. THE CARBON
SEQUESTRATION POTENTIAL THESE
TREES IS ESTIMATED TO BE EIGHTY
ONE THOUSAND POUNDS OF CO TWO
OVER THE LIFETIME OF THE TREES.
THE TREE PLANTINGS WILL ALSO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL BENEFITS BY
ALLEVIATING THE URBAN HEAT
ISLAND EFFECT PROVIDING COOLING
FOR THE COMMUNITY AND CAPTURING
PARTICULATE CONTAMINANTS AND
BALA TILE ORGANIC COMPOUNDS.
THE PROJECT WILL ALSO IMPROVE
STORMWATER CAPTURE TREATMENT
AND INFILTRATION THE POINT
FIGHT WILL CAPTURE AND TREAT A
THIRTY TWO ACRE DRAINAGE AREA
IN THE COMMUNITY BY INSTALLING
SIX DRY WELLS WITHIN THE SITE
TO CLIENTS AND CAPTURE THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
GALLONS OF WATER INFILTRATED.
ALL THIS GONNA HAPPEN ACRE SITE
IN THE MIDDLE OF SOUTHEAST.
MACHINE RESIGNING M. P. M. P.
H. SHE IS AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF EPIDEMIOLOGY
BIOSTATISTICS FOR THE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO PLEASE
WELCOME. ROGERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU TO THE SAMPLING
OF WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK. AND FOR
THE PRESENTATIONS THAT CAME
BEFORE ME THAT WAS SO
INSPIRATIONAL. I AM A
PEDIATRICIAN AND I ALSO RUN A
PROGRAM AND NATURE PRESCRIPTION
PROGRAM WHERE WE TAKE LOW
INCOME FAMILIES INTO NATURE IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR-
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT. AND
DESPITE ALL THE SUFFERING THAT
WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW I REALLY
HAVE CAUSE FOR OPTIMISM IN
NATURE IT IS PART OF MY- TO
LISTEN- NATURE SUCH AS THAT
FOUND IN PARKS AND PUBLIC
LANDS. HAVE ALWAYS BEEN. A
COMMUNITY RESOURCE FOR
RELIEVING STRESS AND ENSURING
HEALTH. AND I COULD GO INTO
DETAIL ABOUT THE RESTORATIVE
EFFECTS OF NATURE ON THE
TENSION CREATIVITY BLOOD
PRESSURE CORTISOL BUT IN
SUMMARY OVER A LIFETIME. LIVING
IN OR NEAR NATURE MAKES US LIVE
LONGER AS WE JUST HEARD-
DESCRIBED BY MS GARCIA
GONZALEZ- IN LOS ANGELES AN
EXAMINATION OF ALL THE CENSUS
TRACTS- SHOW THAT. I'M HAVING
PARKS AND TREE CANOPY NEED. WAS
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASED LIFE
EXPECTANCY TO ME THAT'S A CALL.
TO ACCESS TO. NATURE IS A TOOL
TO ADDRESS DEEPLY ENTRENCHED
HEALTH DISPARITIES AND A STUDY
LOOKING AT THE ENTIRE UNITED.
KINGDOM. CENSUS SHOWED THAT
EXPOSURE TO GREEN STATING
IMPACT OF POVERTY ON.
CARDIOVASCULAR THE DISEASE AND
THAT'S RIGHT IN TEENS- SO IN
OUR GROUP M. AT UCSF WE DID A
NATIONAL SURVEY WE LOOKED AT A
NATIONAL SURVEY STATES AND WE
SAW THAT WHILE ONLY AROUND 25%
ACTUALLY THAT'S PRETTY HIGH OF
CHILDREN HAD REPORTED NO ACCESS
TO PARKS THOSE WHO SAID THEY
HAD NO ACCESS TO PARKS WERE
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE NO.
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY PER WEEK.
MORE THAN FOUR OF DAILY SCREEN
TIME THIS WAS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC- AND INADEQUATE SLEEP.
AND THEY WERE ALSO MORE LIKELY.
TO BE OVERWEIGHT OR TO HAVE AN
ADHD DIAGNOSIS. THE THING
THAT'S REALLY A CALL TO ACTION
OUT FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORLD
IS THAT- EXPOSURE TO NATURE IS
ALSO ONE OF THE METHODS WE
HAVE. TO DECREASE THE SPREAD OF
KUWAIT- SO FIRST OF ALL
EVIDENCE IS ACCUMULATING THAT
NATURE CAN HELP HELP US GET
THROUGH THE MENTAL HEALTH
IMPACTS OF ISOLATION A SURVEY
OF THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE IN.
JAPAN SHOW THAT HAVING A ROOM
THAT HAS YOU WOULD NEED. SURE
OR HAVE VISITS TO NATURE DURING
THE PANDEMIC IMPROVEMENT. SO
HAVE PERMITS THAT CENTERS IN
THE UNITED STATES SHOW THAT.
THERE WAS LESS DISCREPANCY
BETWEEN RACES IN KOBE- RATES SO.
THE RACIAL DISPARITY THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN KOBE WHAT'S LESS IN
AREAS THAT HAD MORE GREEN. AND
THEN MY GROUP THAT A META
ANALYSIS LOOKING AT MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND PAPERS TO SEE
WHERE COKE IT WAS TRANSMITTED
AND WE SAW THAT LESS THAN 10%
OF ALL GLOBAL COATED
TRANSMISSIONS OCCURRED
OUTDOORS.AND AT THE RATE OF IT
THE CHANCE OF GETTING CLOBBERED
OUTDOORS IS ABOUT TWENTY TIMES
LESS THAN IT IS INDOORS AND SO
IN COMBINATION WITH MASKS AND
DISTANCE AND LESS DENSITY.
BEING OUTDOORS IS ACTUALLY AN
INFECTION CONTROL MEASURE. SO
ALL THIS TO SAY AS YOU ALREADY
KNEW ACCESS TO NATURE IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF HEALTH- AND
WE IN PUBLIC HEALTH SHOULD BE
HELPING YOU INCREASE PHYSICAL
ACCESS TO NATURE BUT WE ALL
HAVE TO KNOW AS A GROUP THAT
JUST HAVING NATURE NEAR YOU IS
NOT ENOUGH- AS WE NOTE. THAT
THE- NATURE IS NOT EQUITABLY
DISTRIBUTED IN THE UNITED
STATES NOT HEARD THAT FROM THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER BUT EVEN WHEN
PEOPLE LIVE NEAR NATURE IF IT'S
NOT ASAFE PLACE. THEY WILL NOT
SPEND TIME IN IT- AND WE HAVE
ALL BEEN WITNESSED THIS YEAR
AND IN THE PAST TO REALLY
pAGAINST. PEOPLE IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY- AS WELL AS OTHER
ETHNICITIES LATIN ACTS ASIAN
AMERICANS MUSLIM AMERICANS IN
OUTDOOR SPACES JUST FOR THE
FACT OF BEING OUTSIDE. AND ACTS
LIKE THAT THEY ARE HORRIFIC AND
THEY ARE ALSO SOCIAL SIGNALS.
TO FAMILIES NOT TO BE OUTDOORS
AND NOT TO BE IN NATURE. AND
SURFACE ACCESS IS ONE THING.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO WORK HRD
ON MAKING THESE SPACES RACISM
FREE AND MAKING SURE THAT
FAMILIES FEEL A SENSE OF
OWNERSHIP AND BEING OUTDOORS.
AND IN THE CONTEXT OF COVE IT
THESE TRAGEDIES AND INEQUITIES
ARE SUPER DISTRESSING BECAUSE
THE RIGHT TO BE PHYSICALLY
ACTIVE AND TO PLAY AND TO BE IN
COMMUNITY OUTDOORS. IS ONE OF
THE WAYS THAT WE WILL HEAL.
PANDEMIC SO IN THE LAST FEW
MINUTES I'M JUST GOING TO SHARE
WITH YOU SOME STORIES THAT I'VE
BEEN HEARING FROM MY PATIENTS I
HAVE BEEN LISTENING TO WHAT IS
CLEARLY AN INCREASE IN PARK
VISITOR **** BUT THE KIDS THAT
I WORK WITH- ARE NOT. I DON'T
SEE THEM REFLECTED IN THOSE
NUMBERS SO WE- HAVE BEEN DOING
INTERVIEWS WITH THE FAMILIES
THAT WE SERVE IN THIS URBAN
CLINIC- AND THESE ARE SOME OF
THE QUOTES THAT PEOPLE HAVE
SAID. THERE ARE SOME CITY PARKS
THAT ARE WITHIN WALKING
DISTANCE BUT THEY'RE UNDER
CONSTRUCTION RIGHT NOW OF. IN
WHAT WILL WORK BEST JUST TOOK
ONE PLAY. REALLY THE ONLY TIME
IT UPSIDE. DOWN THE BLOCK AND
I'M THE ONLY JESSICA GB DUE. TO
VIOLENT CRIMES THAT WAS A MONTH.
AND I WISH THERE COULD BE MORE
THINGS FOR CHILDREN TO DO THAT
ARE SAFE AND HEALTHY FOR THEM.
AND THAT THEY FELT ENGAGEMENT.
AND JOY AND I WISH IT WOULD
COULD BE CLOSER IT WASN'T SUCH
A CHALLENGE FOR US TO GET
ACCESS TO IT. REGIONAL PARKS
ARE ALL FAR AWAY FROM WHERE
WE'RE LIVING. WE DON'T HAVE A
CAR. AND SINCE THE PANDEMIC
STARTED THEY'VE CUT DOWN ON BUS
ROUTES AND SUSPENDED A LOT OF
SERVICES. NOBODY'S COMING TO
GIVE US A RIDE ANYWHERE R TO
HELP US IN ANY WAY THAT'S
ANOTHER MONTH. I MISS GOING
OUTSIDE. SOMETIMES I HAVE
DREAMS ABOUT PLAYING IN NATURE
WITH MY STUFFED ANIMALS. AND
THEY COME TO LIFE. THEY CAN
MOVE AND WALK AND TALKON THEIR
OWN. THAT'S A SEVEN YEAR OLD. I
WISH I HAD A BACKYARD BECAUSE
THEN WE COULD GO OUTSIDE AND
ENJOY BEING IN NATURE. TO HAVE
GRASS UNDER YOUR FEET BEING OUT
THERE WITH THE WIND BLOWING.
IT'S MUCH BETTER THAN SITTING
ON THE PORCH LOOKING AT CARS
DRIVING BY WHICH IS NOT ONE OF
OUR FAVORITE THINGS TO DO. I
WISH THAT CODE IT DIDN'T MAKE A
SO CONFINED BECAUSE I THINK
THAT BY CUT CLOSING US OFF FROM
NATURE YOU'VE ALSO CLOSED US
OFF. FROM A PART OF WHO WE ARE
AS PEOPLE. AND AS A COMMUNITY
IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE
IN NATURE AND FEEL LIKE THERE'S
SOMETHING TO DO BESIDES BEING
COOKED COOKED AT HOME UP. AT
HOME SORRY I GET EMOTIONAL.
TAKING THAT AWAY IS HURTING
PEOPLE MORE THAN IT'S HELPING.
EVEN THOUGH WE WANT TO PROTECT
EACH INDIVIDUAL PERSON NATURE
PROVIDES ITS OWN PROTECTION AS
WELL. BECAUSE IT IS NOT GOING
AWAY. SO WE NEED TO FIND A
HEALTHY WAY TO DO IT. AND I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT WE'RE
HEARING ESPECIALLY FROM
FAMILIES WHO HAVE CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS. OR TEENAGERS
THAT THEY ARE REALLY SUFFERING
AT HOME. SO WHAT DO WE DO. I
WANT TO SAY THAT AS PUBLIC
HEALTH PROVIDERS PEOPLE WHO
CARE VERY MUCH ABOUT THE
CONTROL OF CLUB AT NINETEEN. I
FOR ONE AM HERE STANDING WITH
YOU WITH MY SLEEVES ROLLED UP
TO SAY THAT SHELTER IN PLACE
DOES NOT HAVE TO MEAN SHELTER
INSIDE. AND WHAT CAN WE DO TO
HELP YOU MANAGE THIS. INFLUX OF
PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE HAVING
BECAUSE WE REALLY NEED TO AND
WE NEED YOU TO STAY OPEN. WHEN
I SEE PICTURES OF LOTS OF
PEOPLE IN THE PARK I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD THING BECAUSE
THAT'S IN PLACE OF LOTS OF
PEOPLE INSIDE SPREADING MORE
COPE WITH AND THEY WOULD IF
THEY WERE OUTSIDE. PEOPLE
HAVEN'T SEEN THEIR FAMILIES FOR
MORE THAN A YEAR. I WOULD MUCH
RATHER AN EXTENDED FAMILY SPEND
TIME IN THE PARK. THEN IN THEIR
HOME. THE RISK OF COVERT IS
LOWER OUTDOORS AND- I FOR ONE
WOULD EVEN BE HAPPY SEEING
SCHOOLS USE PARKS TO GET
OUTDOORS. AND OTHER ESSENTIAL
SERVICES. HAVE ACCESS TO PUBLIC
LANDS IN ORDER TO STAY OPEN.
THE SECOND THING THAT I THINK
WE CAN DO IS REALLY A LINE HOW
WE SPEAK ABOUT. TIME IN NATURE
AND HOW COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCE
TIME IN NATURE. ACCESS TO
NATURE IS NOT SIMPLY ABOUT
STANDING IN PARKS. HEALING IN
NATURE IS ABOUT PLAYING AND
BEING IN COMMUNITY AND FEELING
GONNA SHIP AND KNOWING THAT
YOUR SPACE AND PARKS. IS VALUED.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN IN
RELATIONSHIP WITH NATURE FOR
ALL OF HUMANITY. BEING IN
NATURE RESONATES WHAT WITH ALL
OF US WHETHER TEACHING TEENS-
CELEBRATION OR IN MY COMMUNITY
PERSIAN NEW YEAR'S COMING UP
AND WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A
BUNCH OF US WORKS IN ABOUT
THREE WEEKS AND I KNOW THOSE OF
YOU FROM LA KNOW THAT FOR SURE.
OKAY SO HOW CAN WE BE MOBILIZED
TO CLEAN. BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE A
LOVE OF NATURE AND I'M IN OUR
CULTURES. AND SO LET US HELP
YOU TAKE CARE OF NATURE BECAUSE
WE NEED IT. VERY MUCH INTO EACH
OF YOU THAT HAVE KEPT YOUR
PROGRAMS FOR TEENAGERS OPEN
THANK YOU THEY ARE IN CRISIS.
THERE'S NO SCHOOL FOR THEM
THERE'S NO VACCINE FOR THEM WE
NEED AS MUCH AS YOU CAN GIVE US
FOR TEENS. LIKE THAT TOO MUCH
TIME I'M SORRY. GOOD THANK YOU
DOCTOR THE PLAINTIFF WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA JUMP INTO SOME
QUESTIONS I KNOW THAT- WE'VE
GOT A- NUMBER OF OTHER
COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE JOINED US.
CAN ADD TEN YOU KNOW FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF QUESTION ANSWERS WE
DO HAVE TWO OF THE PALACE BUT-
YOU'VE ALL BEEN AN EXCELLENT
JOB PRESENTING- THE SUBJECT
MATTERS THAT THEY THINK WE'RE
ALL INTERESTED SO FIRST.
QUESTION WILL COME FROM MY
COLLEAGUE TO MY FAR RIGHT OVER.
HERE MRS REVIEW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION WORK I'M EXCITED
ABOUT THE PLAN AND- YOU KNOW
MAKING SURE THAT OUR KIDS AND
OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE PARK LANDS
I DO HAVE. A QUESTION THOUGH IN
TERMS OF ACCOUNTABILITY I HAVE
A COMMUNITY THAT SOLD- PARKLAND
MY OFFICE IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION. I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THIS PARTICULAR COMMUNITY
FOR OVER TWO YEARS- AND TO TRY
AND RESTART THE LAND- AND WE
HAVEN'T MADE ANY PROGRESS. I
SAW IN THE MEANTIME THOSE KIDS
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ARE
THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT WITHOUT.
THE RECREATION ESPECIALLY
DURING COLD FOOD SO I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK WHAT WHAT
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES. IS THE
COUNTY PUTTING IN PLACE TO
ASSURE THAT- THIS AID THAT THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN. AND HOW
CAN. YOUR SYSTEM PUSHING THAT
COMMUNITY AND TRY TO RESTORE
THE PARK LAND THAT WAS SOLD. A
LONG TIME AGO. TO HAVE THE
DIRECTOR OF A- PARKS AND REC-
WHO COULD POSSIBLY TAKE ON THAT
QUESTION. THE THEIR NUMBER WILL
BE UP FOR THAT QUESTION- GOOD
MORNING- I DO WANT TO MENTION
THAT A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ACTUALLY USES THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE PARK PRESERVATION
ACT WHICH IS A STATE
LEGISLATION ACTUALLY AND IT
GOVERNS ALL OF THE PARK AND
RECREATION ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'M AT PARK
PRESERVATION IS VERY CLEAR IN
REGARDS TO OUR INTERPRETATION
THAT PARKS- PARKS WHERE PARK
FIND A PUBLIC FUNDING HAS BEEN
USED TO PURCHASE- AND DEVELOP-
PARTS MUST BE REPLACED ON A ONE
TO ONE BASIS SO- THE COUNTY IS
NOT THAT. JURISDICTIONAL
AUTHORITY IN REGARDS TO WHERE
IT'S SMALL CITIES- DO YOU- DO
TAKE THOSE ACTIONS- BUT THEY
CAN'T USE THE STATE OUT
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE PARK
PRESERVATION ACT TO HOLD THOSE
CITIES ACCOUNTABLE TO ENSURE
THAT PARKLAND IS REPLACED ON A
ONE TO ONE BASIS AND- IF THERE
IS- IF THERE IS FOR EXAMPLE
REGIONAL PARK AND OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT DOLLARS AND WHICH WERE
INVESTED TO PURCHASE- OR
DEVELOP THAT LAND OF MY AGENCY-
WOULD VERY MUCH I'D BE ENGAGED
IN MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS
ACCOUNTABILITY TO PARK AGENCIES
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY- THAT I
TAKE AWAY PARK LAND AND- THAT
IS I THINK A CONTINUOUS NEED
THAT WE NEED TO- A CONTINUOUS
ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE.
AN EDUCATE CITIES THAT THEY
CAN'T JUST TAKE A PART OF IT IS
THE COMMUNICATED FOR PUBLIC YOU
KNOW FOR PUBLIC USE AND
CONVERTED TO ANOTHER USE AND
ONCE AGAIN WE USE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE- PARK PRESERVATION
ACT- TO EDUCATE AND INFORM OUR
PARTY AGENCIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
PRESERVING PARK LAND AND IF
THERE IS A CHANGE IN USE. THERE
NEEDS TO BE A ONE TO ONE
REPLACEMENT. THANK YOU FOR THAT
AGAIN I DO WORKING WITH THIS
PARTICULAR FOR NOW OVER TO
YEARS ON CHINA TO MOVE ON THAT
IN I HAVEN'T SUCCESS THAT STATE.
HAS ALSO- IMPOSED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE LOT ALONG WITH IT
AND I KNOW ALL WHAT IT'S IN
THERE BECAUSE OF THIS ISSUE AND
SO. SO THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS
TRYING TO HELP I'M TRYING TO
HELP BUT I'M I NEED TO EMPLOY
YOUR HELP BECAUSE IT'S THERE'S
NO MOVEMENT AND AGAIN OUR KIDS
THAT WE ARE SO EXCITED ABOUT
HELPING HAVE BEEN MISSING OUT
AT LEAST. FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS SINCE I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN THIS ISSUE BY THE WAY LONGER
THAN THAN THAN THE TWO YEARS SO
IF I CAN ASK FOR SOME
ASSISTANCE. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU. AND THAT IS THE
MEMBER WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU- TO TRY TO ALSO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
ANY CITY THAT ABSOLUTELY I WILL
REACH OUT TO YOU IN YOUR.
OFFICE SO THAT WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS. AS MEMBER
THIS IS DIRECTOR. BETTER AND I
AM WELL AWARE. THE THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND WE ARE VERY
FOCUSED ON WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND RESOLVING THAT.
REALLY ARE. OUR INTENT
ABSOLUTELY IS TO BE PROVIDING
ACCESS TO. THE PARKS AND PUBLIC
LANDS. AND- AND I APPRECIATE
WHAT. THERE'S NO DOUBT IT'S
JUST SAD BUT WE KNOW IT AND
THIS IS A- OBJECT I'M WELL
AWARE I'M I KNOW WE'RE BOTH. ON
THAT SO LOOK FOR TO WORKING.
THANK YOU JUST WOULD LIKE TO
JUST I REITERATE THAT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE HAND IN HAND AND
WE BUT THEY'VE BEEN FANTASTIC
THEN. AND TRYING TO GET THE
CITY TO MOVE SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR IT FOR THAT ASSISTANCE.
BUT AGAIN IT'S BEEN OVER TWO
YEARS SO MAYBE THERE'S SOME YOU
KNOW WE CAN APPLY SOME LOCAL-
PRESSURE AS WELL BECAUSE IT'S
NOT WE'RE NOT MOVING AND I WANT
TO THANK YOUR DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN. YOU
KNOW LITERALLY HOLDING HAT THAT
THAT CITY'S HAND AND IT'S STILL
THERE'S- BEEN A MOVEMENT I
APPRECIATE THAT. THE WITH A
QUESTION FROM A CALLING FROM
THE SOUNDS AREA FOLLOWED BY
SENEGAL. THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU ALL THE
PRESENTERS- IN PARTICULAR I
THINK THE COMMON THEME AND HAS
BEEN RECEIVING THIS MORNING
WONDERING BECAUSE OF IT. IS THE
SCIENTIFIC BASIS ABOUT HAVING
ACCESS TO OPEN SPACES DOCTORS.
SPOKE VERY SPECIFICALLY TO IT
AS DID- BUT DIRECTOR GARCIA
GONZALEZ AND INCLUDING AND SOME
OF THE MATERIALS THAT SHOW THE
CONNECTION OF FIVE EXPECTANCY
IN ACCESS TO PARK SPACE AND- I
APPRECIATE THE- REFERENCE TO
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER.
ON THE THIRTY PERCENT-
PRESERVATION AS WELL AS
PRESIDENT BIDEN FOLLOWING UP
WITH THAT THAT- THAT PULLED THE-
ABILITIES LAST YEAR MAYBE
THIRTY THIRTY VERY GRATEFUL MY
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES ARE PASSING
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY A
PARTIALLY GOT STALLED ON THE
SENATE SIDE AND- SO GRATEFUL TO
GOVERNOR. INCORPORATED BUT I
THINK IT'S AN EXAMPLE WHEN WE
PUT THINGS FORWARD HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WITHIN A MATTER OF
MONTHS WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
NATIONAL- WE HAVE NATIONAL
LEADERSHIP WITH THE PRESIDENT
ALSO NOW- PROCLAIMING THAT THIS
30% GOAL IS ONE THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR OUR NATION AND
SO- I APPRECIATE. THE GOVERNOR-
BUT IN FOLLOWING THROUGH EVEN
THOUGH THE BILL DID NOT MAKE IT
TO HIS DESK MAKING SURE THAT
THAT ACT THAT THAT ACCESS AND
EQUITY ARE PART OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE I HAVE A
BILL THIS YEAR TO BE THIRTY.
WHICH FOLLOWS UP ON THAT ON ON
HIS ON THE ACCESS PIECE BECAUSE
MUCH LIKE MANY PARTS OF OUR
STATE AND SAN JOSE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE IS GOING TO BE SAN JOSE
THAT MIGHT BE HALF HOUR FROM
THE COAST AND THEY'VE NEVER
SEEN THE OCEAN- EN LA AND OTHER
PLACES THAT YOU SEE A LOT OF
THAT AS WELL BUT I THINK. EVEN
MORE SIGNIFICANTLY AS DIRECTOR
GARCIA IS ALSO REFERRING TO
HELLO THANK THEM THE INTERNAL
PARTS AND YOU MADE HALF ACRE
PARK'S ONE ACRE THIRTY ACRE
PARK CENTER IN- THESE URBAN
DESERT FOR PARTS SO EVEN IN
PLACES LIKE WHEN THEY DO. THESE
RATINGS IN SAN JOSE FOR
EXAMPLE- HOW MUCH. OPEN SPACE
EXISTS WHO HAS I THAT OPENS. IS
A IN YOUR NEIGHBOR. OR IS OPEN
SPACE YOU TO DRIVE TO- YOU KNOW
YOU DEBORAH THE PRIME WE SEEM
LOT OF FOLK. YOU KNOW. RENTING
A HOUSE ON THE BEACH OR- GOING
CAMP FOR A WEEK. WHO WHO IS
THAT ACCESSIBLE AND WAS A NOT
X. TO. AND I THINK THAT FOR. WE
GET AWAY THE NEED FOR US. TO
INVEST I KNOW IT'S HARDER TO
INVEST IN PLACES LIKE. AND IT
WAS DOWNTOWN LA DOWNTOWN SAN
JOSE OR DOWNTOWN OAKLAND.
BECAUSE THE COST OF LAND IS
MORE THERE'S SO MUCH. PRESSURE
TO DEVELOP IT. FOR YOU KNOW FOR
PROFIT AND FOR THOSE THAT WANT
TO. CONTINUE TO. DENSIFY AND
SO. AS WE GO FORWARD NOT JUST
WITH THEM. ONE OF THE- 30%
GOALS WHAT HAVE YOU. BUT AS WE
MOVE THAT'S BEEN REFERRED TO
THE CLIMB UP ON WHAT HAVE YOU-
HOW DO WE ENSURE. THAT. WE ARE.
YEAH AND THIS GOES TO A CENTER
WILL BE POINT AS WELL JUST IN A
MORE SENSE. HOW DO WE ENSURE.
THAT WE'RE GETTING THESE OPEN
SPACES AND PARKS IN
COMMUNITIES. THAT NEED IT. AS A
PRIORITY BECAUSE- I KNOW THAT.
SOMETIMES IS THE PATH OF LEAST
RESISTANCE WE CAN. PRESERVE
SOME SPACE YOU KNOW THE ONLY
WAY OUT OF URBAN AREAS IT MIGHT
BE EASIER TO DO THAT. TO BUY UP
MAYBE SOME FORMER RENTAL AND
THE MAKE IT OFFICE SPACE. IT'S
MUCH HARDER TO DO THE WORK EVEN
OF OUR URBAN COMMUNITIES AND SO
IS THERE A THOUGHT OR A PLAN OF
HOW WE CAN GO FORWARD. TO
PRIORITIZE IT EVEN THOUGH WE
KNOW THAT'S THE HARDER WORK.
THAT SOMETIMES ENDS UP. PUTTING
BEING IN THE- KIND OF THE END
OF THE LAST AND THEN AS OF NOW
GETTING DONE. BUT IF ANYONE
OTHER. TO GET BACK TO THAT WORK
SO A LONG WINDED WAY OF SAYING
HOW TO BE FIRED. THESE INFILL
URBAN PARKS IN A PARK DESERT'S.
THIS IS THE RECORD THAT- I'D
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THE
STATEMENT IN QUESTION. WELL
THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS I'D
LIKE TO MENTION TWO THINGS IS
THAT IN OUR BUDGET THIS YEAR WE
HAVE A LOT OF TIMES. WE HAVE
OVER TEN MILLION DOLLARS
APPROVED IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE NEW LAND ACQUISITIONS FOR
THE STATE PARK SYSTEM. THAT WE
ARE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'RE LOOKING AT IS- IN
OUR PRIORITY LIST LOOKING AT
INTERNAL PIECES THAT WILL MAKE
A BIG DIFFERENCE FOR PARKS THAT
ARE IN. NEAR COMMUNITIES BUT
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO EXPANDING
STATE PARK TO LARGER AREAS AND
WE LOOK FORWARD VERY MUCH TO BE
ABLE TO BEAT MAKING SOMEONE
ELSE BUT THEN THE NEXT IN THE
NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS. BUT THERE'S
ANOTHER PROGRAM THAT'S REALLY
CRITICAL OF IN STATE PARKS
THERE IS A COMMUNITY GRANTS
PROGRAM WHICH SINCE THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND HAS INVESTED
ALMOST THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE NOT ON
STATE PARK PROPERTY. AND THESE
ARE INVESTMENTS IN PAYING FOR
THINGS LIKE NATURE CENTER'S
REBUILDING CLARK'S ESTABLISHING
TRAILS. PUTTING IN THINGS LIKE
COMMUNITY POOLS AND IT'S A GIRL
I HAVE TWO GOALS AND- WE WILL
THIS YEAR WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED
AND NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN GRANT FNDS. WHICH WE ARE
GOING TO BE DIRECTING TO
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IN A LITTLE LATER
TODAY YOU'LL BE HEARING. A
PRESENTATION BY CEDRIC MITCHELL
WHO RUNS THAT OFFICE SO HE'LL
GO INTO MORE DETAIL ABOUT IT
BUT I JUST WANT. TO LET YOU
KNOW. THAT ONE OF THE- IT
PRIORITIES FIRST PARKS THIS
YEAR. YEAH TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MAKING A KNOWN. THAT STATE PARK
ARE ACTUALLY COMING TO YOUR-
AND JUSTIN IN THOSE VERY- THAT.
ALLOW FOLKS TO GIVE TE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECREATION CLOSE
TO HOME. AND MY INTENTION IS
THAT MAKE THOSE INVESTMENTS
THERE WILL ALSO BE MESSAGING
THAT SAYS. THESE PARTS ARE
YOURS AND THESE PARKS ARE YOURS
SO THAT PEOPLE KNOW. THAT PARKS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. PART OF
THEIR CITIZENSHIP. AND I'M VERY
MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO GETTING
THOSE MESSAGES OUT. TO MAKING%
SURE THAT. THAT CITIZENS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE START
SEEING THAT THERE ARE LOCAL
INVESTMENTS COMING TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES BY VIRTUE OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND- THE EFFORTS OF
THE SAME ARTIST GRANTS MANAGERS
FOR THESE AREAS. WE HAVE THREE
GRANTS PROGRAMS ACTUALLY NOT
ONLY IN OUR OFFICE IN FRANCE
HERE. PARKS BUT IN DEPARTMENT
OF BUILDING AND WATERWAYS WE
MANAGE GRANTS. FOR WATER ACCESS
OPPORTUNITIES THINGS LIKE NEW
PROGRAMS. AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS TO HELP THE STATE. WE
ALSO HAVE A GRANTS PROGRAM IN
OUR OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE PROGRAM
WHICH ACTUALLY MAKES
INVESTMENTS IN LAND
ACQUISITION. AREAS THAT ARE NOT
IN STATE PARKSAND HELP RESTORE
LANDS AND ALSO MAKE PLANS
AVAILABLE FOR ADDITIONAL- H. B.
USE AND I'VE- I'M PARTICULARLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS IN A VERY
QUICK STORY IS THAT. I USED TO
WORK AT UC MERCED FOR A
THOUSAND YEARS. AND ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES A COUPLE MY
COLLEAGUES WENT WITH ME TO THE
ADJACENT OPEN SPACE TO USE THE
WORDS AND IT'S OUT OF VERNAL
POOL. COMPLEX VERY WHERE
LANDSCAPE. A YOUNG WOMAN WHO
MONEY FOR THE IN. WE OUT THERE
FOR A COUPLE DAYS WITH THIS IS
WE UP WITH SCIENCE AND RE. AND
SECOND MORNING AFTER WE GET OUT
OF OUR TEN AND WAIT UP YES YOU
WOMAN. WHO WAS RAY IN RECESS
WENT TO SCHOOL TO. IN NOW IT'S
BACK IN VERSE. SHE CAME OUT
TOWARD A GROUP OF A LOOK LIKE
SHE WAS. AND I HAD A ARE YOU
OKAY. AND SHE WAS. AND SHE
SAID. I DIDN'T KNOW I. LIVED
HERE MMHM. AND I THINK THAT WE
AS A BROADER. AND ITS PUBLIC
LANDS LEADERS AND AS PUBLIC
LAND PROFESSIONALS. HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE DOES THAT
VERY EXPERIENCE. FOR
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BECAUSE I DO THINK. THAT
A PART OF THE VALUE HERE IS
GIVING ALL THE STUDENTS AND-
THE UNDERSTANDING IN THE SENSE
OF OWNERSHIP. AND PARTICIPATION
IN THE PUBLIC LANDS WORLD OF.
THE MOST INCREDIBLE STATE IN
THE NATION CALIFORNIA. I
APPRECIATE THAT AND WOULD JUST
SAY DIRECTORS INTO TO AVOID-
MAN AND COME TO US IF YOU IF
YOU'RE FINDING THE PATH OF
LEAST RESISTANCE TO BE ONE THAT
GOES BACK TO THE NORM BECAUSE
THERE'S BEEN AN ISSUE FOR A
VERY LONG TIME. AND I WOULD
JUST SAY THE LAST COMMENTS ON
GRANT PROGRAMS I KNOW THE VERY
TOP THIS IS TALKED ABOUT IN
TERMS OF CAMPAIGN ACCOUNT BY
ASKING WHAT HAVE YOU BUT YOU
KNOW A PLACE WHERE I LIVE- WE
ARE WORKING CLASS COMMUNITIES
AND YES THE PROPERTY VALUE
MIGHT BE HIGHER. BUT YOU HAVE
YET TO THREE FAMILIES AGAIN AND
A HOME AND THEY DON'T HAVE
PARTS IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD AND
SO THERE CAN BE WAYS AS WE LOOK
AT THESE GRANT PROGRAMS TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE FACT THAT EVEN
THOUGH SOMEONE IS ON A HIGH
COST OF LIVING AREA- HIGH
PROPERTY VALUE AREA THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THOSE
FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS. SO WE CAN
NARROW DOWN AND TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AS TO REALLY. CREATING
THAT MANY BLACKS SO THANK YOU.
I YOU SOME- COMMON. THEME HERE
IS THE ISSUE POOR PART. CAN YOU.
IN HIGH PERCENTAGE. OF A- PER.
KILLED PEOPLE IN. CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES AND SO CERTAINLY
SOME FOLLOW UP ON TERMS OF
LANGUAGE. WHEN WE'RE- PUTTING
TOGETHER. SECTIONS FOR THESE
PARTS- GRADS SOME. HOPE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SENEGAL WOULD
LIKE TO ASK QUESTIONS. GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE
PRESENTATIONS HERE TODAY A LOT
OF HELPFUL INFORMATION REALLY
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS AS
WELL COMING FROM AN URBANIZED
NEIGHBORHOOD AS WELL WE'RE
DEALING WITH THAT. DELTA
ENVIRONMENTS AND MAKING SURE
THAT ALL PARTS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. HOW THAT- BOTH
ACCESS TO EXISTING STATE PARKS
AND ALSO FUTURE OPPORTUNITIES-
BUT I ALSO HAVE THAT BLESSING
OF BEING ABLE TO REPRESENT A
BEAUTIFUL PART OF THE COAST
LINE WITH A LOT OF GREAT STATE
PARKS AND BEACHES. IN THE SEVEN
EIGHT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND WE
KNOW. ARE PARTICULARLY ACUTELY
DOWN THERE HOW. USED ARE STATE
PARKS FACILITIES ARE. ON TOP OF
THAT WE'RE WELL AWARE OF THE
IMPACTS THAT WERE FEARING UNDER
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SO DIRECTOR
CAN TERRA WAS WONDERING IF YOU
COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
WHAT YOUR DEPARTMENT IS DOING
NOW- TO DETERMINE WHAT SEA
LEVEL RISE MIGHT MEAN TO MANY
OF OUR STATE PARKS AND THE
FACILITIES THAT ARE THERE- ANY
PLANS OF ACTIONS TO BE ABLE TO.
ADOPT OR TO MITIGATE FOR THAT.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR THAT. IS
THAT MEMBERS TAKE PART IS JEFF.
FINISHED A SEA LEVEL RISE
ADAPTATIONS ADAPTATION
STRATEGY. AND IT LAYS OUT A
ROADMAP. TO BUILD A RAPPER NOW
TO RESPONSE FOR SEA LEVEL RISE.
OR THE COASTAL STATE PARK UNITS
ALL ALONG THE COAST STATE PARKS
ACTUALLY MANAGES OVER THREE
HUNDRED MILES. OF THE COASTLINE
OF CALIFORNIA SO THIS IS A VERY
CRITICAL ISSUE FOR ALL OF US.
AND SOMEBODY IDENTIFIED ACTIONS
ARE ALREADY BEING IMPLEMENTED
FOR EXAMPLE. OR SOME OF THE-
ACTIONS ARE ALREADY BEING
IDENTIFIED AND WE'RE ALSO
PRIORITY PRIORITIZING OTHERS AS
WE WERE ABLE TO GET FUNDING.
PARTNERSHIPS AND ADDITIONAL
ORGANIZATIONAL CAPACITY- YOUR
QUESTION IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN OUR ADAPTATION
STRATEGY IS LOOKING. TO WHAT
KINDS OF ACTIONS DO WE NEED TO
TAKE NOW IF WE'RE LOOKING AT A
SEA LEVEL RISE OF SAY THREE
FEET OVER THE NEXT FORTY YEARS.
AND IT REALLY MAKES A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE KINDS
OF PROJECTS THAT WE IMPLEMENT-
HOW WE MANAGE ACCESS AND HOW WE
LOOK AT THE SAUDIS AND ALL OF
THAT SO IT'S A- IT'S A VERY
HIGH PRIORITY FOR US AND I WILL
ALSO SAY. THAT WITH STATE PARKS
WE'RE WORKING WITH ORIGINATION
LAND MANAGEMENT AGENCIES WERE
ACTUALLY A MEMBER OF WAR WE
WORK WITH A GROUP CALLED
CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE
STEWARDSHIP NICHE. STEWARDSHIP
NETWORK AND WHAT WE DO THERE IS
WE WORK WITH PARTNERS SO THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST WORKING IN A
POCKET IN ONE AREA WE'RE
WORKING AS A COLLECTIVE. WITH
OTHER LAND MANAGERS IN THE AREA
BECAUSE WE REALLY NEED TO BE
OPERATING. IN A WATERSHED SCALE
IS WORKING FOR GOING TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE EFFECTIVE DECISIONS AND
EFFECTIVE INVESTMENTS. INTO
THESE PARTNERSHIPS I'VE SEEN.
BASICALLY A FORCE MULTIPLIER OF
KNOWLEDGE. OF RESOURCES IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE AND FUNDING AND
ALSO PROBLEMS THAT ACTUALLY
HAVE. OR SOLUTIONS TO PROBLEMS
AND HAVE A MUCH. BROADER.
APPLICATION AND IMPACT. GREAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT- IF OUR
DIRECTOR LAYERS WITH US WITHOUT
AND WILD. I REALLY THOUGHT THE
SAME THEREFORE THREE YEARS
APART- WHAT ARE YOU DOING FOR
LANDS THAT MIGHT BE. AFFECTING
WELL THAT MIGHT BE AT RISK FOR
SEA LEVEL RISE- TO BE ABLE TO
THICK AND MITIGATE OR ADAPT OUT
FOR SOME OF THE WILDLIFE
PROGRAMS- AND THOSE IMPACTS WE
EXPECT FROM CLIMATE CHANGE.
THANK YOU. SUM OF MEMBER. WE
ARE CURRENTLY WORKING THROUGH
OUR PROPOSITION ONE PROP SIXTY
EIGHT GRANT PROGRAMS TO
HIGHLIGHT THOSE. ARE AREAS OF
RESTORATION OR REMEDIATION. FOR
THOSE POTENTIAL HABITAT THAT
WOULD BE EITHER LOST OR ENTER
DATED AS C. LEVEL RISE OCCURS.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING AS DIRECTOR
CAN TERO TALKED ABOUT THE
LANDSCAPE SCALE PARTNERSHIP
WITH CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE- OUR-
PARTNERSHIP- THE- ISSUE IS. ALL
THIS WAS HIGH A LOT OF THESE-
WILDLIFE AREAS OR ECOLOGICAL
RESERVES ARE- DOWN BY URBAN
DEVELOPMENT AND THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF ROOM TO GO WHERE THE SEA
LEVEL RISES AND WE CAN USE SOME
OF THE IN LINE BECAUSE I MEAN
THE COASTAL LAGOON HABITATS
THAT ARE SO ESSENTIAL FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND
BIODIVERSITY- WHAT HAPPENS AS
THE SEA LEVEL RISE IS. AND
INTIMIDATION OCCURS- UPWARD IN
THE CHANNEL SO WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT STRATEGIC
RESTORATION OR REMEDIATION
PROJECTS WITHIN THE FOOTPRINT
ALLOWED OR SEEK ADDITIONAL
ACQUISITIONS BORDERING THOSE
PROPERTIES TO ENSURE THAT THE
HABITATS ARE MAINTAINED. AND I
THINK THAT IT'S A IT'S A BIG
LEFT- WORKING ACROSS MULTIPLE
AGENCIES WHETHER IT'S THE
COASTAL COMMISSION LOCAL
PLANNING DEPARTMENTS STATE
PARKS AND OTHER- FEDERAL OR
STATE AGENCIES THAT MANAGE
THOSE HABITATS SO IT'S
BASICALLY EVERYBODY'S GOT A
LEAD INTO THIS BECAUSE NO ONE
ENTITY IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND QUICK ENOUGH AND
THERE'S SOME REALLY GOOD MODELS
OUT THERE AND THEN THE NATIONAL
LANDSCAPE. HOW THE GULF COAST
COMMUNITIES IN FLORIDA AND THE
BARRIER ISLANDS ARE ADDRESSING
HOW CLIMATE CHANGE AND SEA
LEVEL RISE WILL AFFECT CENTRAL-
CRITICAL WILDLIFE AND
ECOLOGICAL HABITATS- NECESSARY
TO MAINTAIN THE BIODIVERSITY OF
THE PLANET. THANK YOU AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU SAID
IT IS GOING TO TAKE ALL OF US
ON VERY SENSITIVE AREAS LIKE
THE TIJUANA RIVER ESTUARY IN
MISSION BAY AND OTHER SPACES
THAT EVEN AN URBANIZED
ENVIRONMENT- PROVIDE GREAT
RESOURCE FOR A LOT OF OUR- BOTH
MIGRATORY AND- REALLY STAT TAKE
A- FOUND SO- ONE OF. WITH YOU
ON AND I WILL STAY IN TOUCH AND
I'M SURE A LOT OF GONNA BE
THERE AND AS A WORKING THE- OF
BOND RELATED. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COLLEAGUES. PROTESTED YOU
SO MUCH. YOUR PARTICIPATION I
HAVE ONE QUESTION I THINK ALL
OF YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO.
RESPOND TO IT AS WE CLOSE UP
THIS A PANEL PRESENTATION.
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
PANDEMIC AND OTHER CHALLENGES
THE PAST YEAR THE YOU DID NOT
HAVE THE CHANCE TO SPEAK ON
DURING YOUR TESTIMONY WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR. HOW YOUR YOUR
THOUGHTS AND PERSPECTIVES ON
THAT MAYBE A MINUTE OR SO
RESPONSE- THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
THANK YOU. ON THIS SUBJECT IN
BATTLE TO START VERY QUICKLY
WHAT WE DID WITH THE PARKS AS
WE LOOK. AT HOW WE CAN CONTINUE
TO MAKE PARKS ACCESSIBLE TO THE
PUBLIC. BECAUSE EVERYONE IS
STATED WE HAD TREMENDOUS
INCREASES IN PUBLIC VISITATION
APART. WELL WE HAD TO BE REALLY
CAREFUL TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE PROTECTING FOLKS FROM-
ACTIVITIES IT COULD CREATE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONTAMINATION
SO WE HAD TO DO THINGS LIKE
REMOVE PICNIC TABLES AND WE
MADE SURE THAT WHEN PEOPLE CAME
TO PARKS. THEY WERE INFORMED WE
SHOULD BE SIMPLY DISTANCE IS
USUALLY THE PATIENT KEEP
MOVING. AND WHAT WE DID IS WE
USE ALL THE FORMS OF MEDIA TO
GET THE MESSAGE OUT. ON OUT
WHERE PEOPLE COULD GO WHAT
KINDS OF ACTIVITIES THEY COULD
ENGAGE IN- BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
WHAT WE DID IS WE TOOK. THE
GOVERNOR'S DIRECTIVE IN TERMS
OF STAYING AT HOME. AND
EMPLOYEES AND WE WORK WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
MAKE SURE. THAT AS WE MAKE
CHANGES RELATIVETO PUBLIC
ACCESS. ON AND HOW WE MANAGE
PUBLIC ACCESS TO PARKS WHAT IN
LINE WITH WHAT WAS HAPPENING
COUNTYWIDE. AND WHAT WE FOUND
WAS INCREDIBLE PARTNERSHIP WITH
CITY REGIONAL AND FEDERAL LAND
AGENCIES WE ALL ENDED UP.
BASICALLY MOVING IN CONCERT.
AND I'M VERY PROUD TO SAY THAT
IT WAS. STATE PARKS LEADERS.
BACK IN MARCH OF TWENTY. WELL
THE I CAME ON BOARD AS IT. AND
ACTUALLY PUT THE- TOGETHER I
HOPE HOW WE COULD MOVE FORWARD.
IN BOTH AN ADAPTIVE MANNER AS
WELL AS A COOPERATIVE MANNER
WITH OTHER- PARK FARM PUBLIC.
AGENCY NO BE THERE. THANK THANK
YOU. AND I'D JUST LIKE- MISTER
CHAIR STATE ONE OF THE BIG
THINGS THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE HAS-
RECOGNIZED. AND I THINK IN OUR
CURRENT BUDGET YEAR-
APPROPRIATION AND ALSO IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JAN TEN BUDGET. IS
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED TO KEEP
OUR OPEN SPACES OPEN AND ALSO
MAKE THEM WELCOME. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY AND WHAT WE
FOUND IS. MANY PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
BROAD LANDSCAPE- MENTORSHIP AND
STEWARDSHIP RESPONSIBILITY. SO
HOW DO WE PROVIDE APPROPRIATE
SIGNAGE INFORMING THEM THAT
IT'S OPEN AND WELCOME HELLO WE
HAVE NATIVE AMERICAN AG
KNOWLEDGE MEANT OF THAT LAND
HOW DO WE DISCUSS THE VALUES OF
THAT LAND IN TERMS THEN-
APPROPRIATE- LANGUAGE THAT THEY
CAN HELP UNDERSTAND WHY IS THIS
IMPORTANT TO THEM. IN THEIR
COMMUNITY HEALTH SO WE ARE
MOVING RAPIDLY INTO THAT SPACE
APPROPRIATE SANITATION
FACILITIES APPROPRIATE SIGNAGE
AND APPROPRIATE ACCESS POINTS
SO I THINK THAT THE- MEANING
INTO IT AND KEEPING OPEN SPACES
OPEN AND MAKING- WELCOME TO ALL
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA IS ESSENTIAL
AS WE MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE I'LL
PREDICT. IT MAY NOT BE CORONA
VIRUS IN THE CODEPENDENT
SOMETHING. ELSE WILL COME NEXT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DIRECTOR I.
PLANO THAT- MY CALL AND I I'M
SURE MANY OF OUR OTHER.
COLLEAGUES HERE WE APPRECIATE
THE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF NATIVE
AMERICAN- IDENTIFICATION AT OUR
STATE PARK SAID NESS ASIDE FROM
KIND OF THE RESPECT THAT THE
THAT IT THEY DESERVE IT IT'S
ALSO EDUCATIONAL TO LET
CALIFORNIANS AND OTHERS
VISITING- OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE
PARKS THE YOU KNOW THE
TRADITIONAL PEOPLES. WHO WERE
THERE PRIOR TO US AND THAT
BECOMES THE PART THANK YOU- I
LOVE ANOTHER AGAIN SAME
QUESTION FOR THE OTHER TWO
PALACE AND THEN WE'LL WRAP UP
SO THAT WE CAN GET INTO THE
NEXT- PANEL. OKAY CHECKERS YEAH
I WOULD- I'D LIKE TO MENTION.
THAT FOR US WE- I THINK I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE CHARM
LEANING AND PARK AND RECREATION
SECTOR UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REALLY NEEDS AND- TO
PROVIDE SAFETY AND SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO. OUR COMMUNITIES
AND REALLY PIVOTED IN VERY
INNOVATIVE WAYS- IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WE ARE ENGAGED AND
ACTUALLY MEETING EVERY PARK AND
RECREATION DIRECTOR IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. HAS BEEN
MEETING ON A BI MONTHLY BASIS.
I'M REALLY LOOKING AT
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO SERVICING
OUR DIRECTLY IN OUR- JOINTLY
OUR CONSTITUENCIES. ALSO I DO
WANT TO SAY THAT ONE OF THE
LESSONS LEARNED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF JUST
COLLABORATING. ACROSS
JURISDICTIONAL BOUNDARIES AND
THAT'S TO ME THAT'S A VERY
STRONG ACCOUNTING SO AS PUBLIC
HEALTH RESTRICTIONS I WOULD BE
MODIFIED. IT WAS NOT ABOUT WHAT
CAN NOT WE CAN'T DO BUT IT WAS
MORE ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO. AND
I WILL ALSO JUST WANT TO
MENTION IN HIGHLIGHT THE
THOUSANDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PARKING RECOGNITION. A RANGERS.
PARK STAFF GROUNDS MAINTENANCE
STAFF WHO LEGALLY LEGAL DAN.
AND I THINK FOR ME THE LESSON
LEARNED IS THAT WE NEED TO
REALLY MARKET- THE IMPORTANT
WORK THAT THEY HAVE DONE
THROUGHOUT THIS CON- THIS
PANDEMIC. WELL I DON'T WANT TO
MINIMIZE. THE THAT THE CRITICAL
VALUE OF OUR HEALTH WORKERS ARE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. BUT OUR
PARK AND RECREATION TEAMS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE HAVE BEEN ON
THE FRONT LINES REALLY
SUPPORTING THE WELL BEING OF
OUR COMMUNITIES- AND I THINK
THAT WE IN THE SAME WAY. NEED
TO FURTHER- REALLY HIGHLIGHT-
THIS WORKFORCE THAT IS BEEN
GIVING CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS ALL.
OF THIS ENTIRE TIME DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THANK SO MUCH TALK-
WILL NOT GIVE YOU THE FINE WORD
IN USE FOR. OF QUITE A BIT
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE ACTS TO
THE BAR. BUT TO THE MEN BECAUSE-
SPIRITUAL- ANDY AND A CALL THAT
WE SEE- HAS BEEN SOLD NOT
BOUGHT IF YOU WANT TO. KIND OF.
FINAL WORDS FOR THE A PANEL.
WHAT WILL IT FOR HIT WE
ACTUALLY BENEFITED FROM THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WERE BUILT
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS BETWEEN
PARKS AND HEALTH- FOLKS IN THE
BAY AREA WE HAVE BEEN MEETING
UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF HEALTHY
PARKS HEALTHY PEOPLE AND WHAT
WE FOUND WAS THAT- MANY PARK
DISTRICTS AND LAND MANAGERS
WERE REALLY RECEIVING MIXED
MESSAGES ABOUT WHAT TO DO- AND
SINCE WE STARTED MEETING FIRST
ON A WEEKLY BASIS- AND THEN WE
ACTUALLY ENDED UP PUTTING
TOGETHER A SERIES OF THREE
WEAPON ARTISTS WITH
EPIDEMIOLOGIST. AND INFECTIOUS
DISEASES PEOPLE GIVING
INFORMATION TO PEOPLE IN PARKS
BECAUSE AS WAS MENTIONED REALLY
PEOPLE PARKS ARE VERY MUCH ON
THE FRONT LINES OF DEALING WITH
THE PANDEMIC AND- PUBLIC HEALTH
POLICIES WHICH WERE NOT
HAPPENING IN A REGION WHERE
WE'RE THROWING UP PARK
MINISTRY- SOFT BECAUSE THEN THE
POLICIES OF ONE COUNTY WOULD
IMPACT- YOU KNOW IT WOULD LEAD
PEOPLE TO ALL FLOCK TO ANOTHER
COUNTY'S. IF BUT PARKS IN ONE
DISTRICT WERE CLOSED AND SO WE
REALLY TRY TO HELP CREATE
CONSISTENT MESSAGING AND TO BE
GENERALIZATION FROM THE HEALTH
SIDE TO PARKS AND I THINK THAT
THE U. INVITING ME TO THIS AND-
MORE INTO YOU KNOW IF WE CAN DO
THE SAME AND HAVE MORE INTO HER
DISCIPLINARY- DISCUSSIONS WE
REALLY WILL BE PREPARED FOR.
THE NEXT PANDEMIC WHICH I AGREE
IS COMING AS WELL AS THE IMPACT
OF CLIMATE CHANGE- I THINK THAT
PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THE
OUTDOORS AND PEOPLE THAT WORK
IN PARKS ARE ARE ACTUALLY
FACING VERY MUCH ARE VERY
SIMILAR ISSUES AND WE ARE BOTH
VERY IMPACTED BY INEQUITY
BECAUSE INEQUITY DRIVES. A LOT
OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE SEE IN
HEALTH AND I'M SURE THAT IT.
DRIVES A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT YOU SEE. I MEAN CAN FOR
OUT PARKS WHY- AND- BUT I'D
START THE WHOLE SO AND I'M- NH
AS PART OF OPTIMA. WE HAVE A
VACCINE WHICH IS LIKE
UNBELIEVABLE WE SHOULD ALL BE
REALLY CELEBRATING THAT IT'S A-
GREAT THING- AND I HOPE THAT
OUR DISCIPLINES CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO. MAKE THE SUCCESS-
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL- YOU DON'T
FEEL LIKE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
ALL POPULATIONS CAN TRUST. AND
THAT PARK FOLKS WHO ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS HAVE ACCESS
TO IT- AND SO I THINK REALLY
FOR ME IT'S THE RELATIONSHIPS
BUILT BETWEEN. THESE VERY
DIFFERENT DISCIPLINES CARING
FOR THE HEALTH OF PEOPLE ON THE
PLANET- THAT WE QUOTE UNQUOTE
LIED AND LEANED INTO AND THE
TRUTH WE WILL NEED TO KEEP
LEANING INTO TO BE PREPARED.
FOR WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU AGAIN DR
AND ALL OF THE S. THE PALACE
THIS MORNING WE WENT BACK OVER
BUT GOOD INFORMATION IMPORTANT
INFORMATION WE ASKED THE
QUESTION WE WANTED TO KNOW AND
I THINK IT WAS- WORKED UP. THE
EXTENDED TIME THAT WE ADDED SO
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US WE WILL WE WILL GET
BACK TO OUR DIRECTORS YOU KNOW
WE DO HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
DIVERSITY. HIRING AS WE- YOU
KNOW BEEF UP SERVICES AND
INVESTMENTS AND THINGS OF THAT
SORT BUT AGAIN TODAY'S- FOCUS
WAS THE ISSUE OF THE PANDEMIC-
THE CURRENT STATUS OF OUR STATE
PARKS AND OF COURSE THE STIRS
ACCESS ISSUES. AT THAT- BEEN
BROUGHT UP SO THANK YOU AGAIN
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT- PANEL
AND THAT'S A FUNNY AN OVERVIEW
AND IMPLEMENTATION UPDATE WE
HAVE A PRIME BROWN FROM THE
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AND CEDRIC MITCHELL
DEPUTY DIRECTR OF EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION SO WE'LL DIVE RIGHT
INTO THE- ELLUL REPORT AND THEN
NOT GET THAT WITH THE DIRECTOR
OF- EXTERNAL AFFAIRS FROM THE
PARKS AND REC. AGENCY SO
WELCOME- BRIAN BROWN FLOORS
YOURS. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- CAN.
THIS CHAIR MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE- NAME IS BRYAN BROWN.
FROM YOUR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. IN THE COMMITTEE AFTER
THEY GIVE A BRIEF- SISKEL
OVERVIEW- FUNDING FOR PARKS AND
OPEN SPACE IN CALIFORNIA. YOU
SHOULD HAVE A HAND OUT THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO THE COMMITTEE- AN
OLD NOTE FOR THE PUBLIC TO
THAT'S AVAILABLE ON. OUR
WEBSITE LA- AUTO DOT CA DOT GOV
SO THAT'S- ANYONE CAN DOWNLOAD
THAT WOULD LIKE TO FOLLOW ALONG
I'M IN THE INTEREST OF TIME-
THE HEAD OF THE SELF IS. JUST
SIX OR SEVEN PAGES BUT ALL ALL
GO THROUGH PRETTY QUICKLY I
WILL GO THROUGH PEOPLE LOOK
WENT ON TO IS THE HIGHLIGHT. OF
THE HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT
THE END- IF THE- NUMBER OF
PLEASURE SO I'M IF YOU TURN TO
THE FIRST PAGE ONE OF THE HAND
OUT WE DO HIGHLIGHT. SOME OF
THE MAJOR FUNDING SOURCES FOR
PARKS AND OPEN SPACE IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S OF COURSE. A
VARIETY OF STATE FUNDING USED
FOR BOTH. STATE PARK IN LOCAL
PARKS- THERE'S STATE GENERAL
FUND OR SPECIAL FUNDING OF
COURSE GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND.
ARE COMMONLY USED THERE'S A
SIMILARLY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THERE'S LOCAL TAX REVENUE-
LOCAL BONDS AND ALSO LOCAL. A
SPECIAL FUND REVENUES FROM
VISITOR FEES. WE HAVE A
RELATIVELY SMALL AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT'S
AVAILABLE FOR PARKS RELATIVE TO
THE AMOUNT SPENT BY STATE AND
LOCAL. FUNDS AND OF COURSE OUR
NON PROFIT PARTNERS ALSO
PROVIDE FUNDS FOR DIFFERENT
PROJECTS AND PARKS. TO SUPPORT
THOSE ACTIVITIES. IF TURN TO
PAGE TWO- PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
MORE. IN DETAIL SPECIFICALLY ON
STATE PROGRAMS AND SO OF COURSE
OUR LARGEST PROGRAM FIRST PARKS
AND OPEN SPACE IN CALIFORNIA AT
THE STATE LEVEL. IS OUR STATE
PARKS DEPARTMENT YOU HEARD
FROM- THE DIRECTOR AT THE IN
THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR THE
BUDGET PROVIDES ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT- YOU'LL SEE IN THE
PIE CHART THAT. ROUGHLY HALF OF
THAT IS FROM WHAT WE CONSIDER
ONGOING. I'M SURE THIS IS SUCH
IN GENERAL FIND IN STATE PARKS
AND RECREATION FOR UNDER THE
TWO LARGEST SOURCES. WE DO ALSO
HAVE A LARGE AMOUNT IN THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET FROM STATE
BOND THAT'S PRIMARILY
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT WHICH
ALL SPEAK TO IN JUST A MOMENT.
AND THEN A SMALLER SHARE OF
FEDERAL FUNDS IMPORTANTLY THE
TOTAL FUNDING YOU SEE HERE THE
ONE POINT THREE BILLION. ABOUT
HALF OF THAT IS TO SUPPORT OUR
STATE PARK SYSTEM- BOTH
OPERATIONS AND CAPITAL PROJECTS
AND THEN ABOUT HALF. IS FOR-
GRANTS TO LOCAL AND REGIONAL
PARKS AND MUCH OF THAT IS AGAIN
FROM THE BOND FUNDING. IF YOU
GO TO PAGE THREE OF THE HANDOUT
DO WANNA HIGHLIGHT THAT OF
COURSE IN ADDITION TO PARTS OF
THE STATE. OTHER CLICK ACCESS-
PROGRAMS- DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE YOU'VE YOU'VE HEARD
FROM HAS OF COURSE IT'S HUNTING
AND FISHING PROGRAM AS WELL AS
AS A DEPUTY DIRECTOR MENTIONED
THEY COULD MANAGE ONE POINT ONE
MILLION ACRES OF THEIR OWN
LANDS AS WELL AS YOU HAVE A
LITTLE INFORMATION ON THOSE
PROGRAMS THEY ARE THE FUNDING
SOURCES FOR SUPPORT THOSE- AND
THEN OF COURSE IN ADDITION WE
HAVE. OTHER PROGRAMS AS WELL
WHEN I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FOR
YOU IS THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY HAS A RELATIVELY NEW
PROGRAM IS JUST GETTING OFF THE
GROUND NOW IT'S THE YOUTH
COMMUNITY ACCESS GRANT PROGRAM
THIS IS FUNDED BY A CANNABIS
TAX REVENUES IN THIS PROVIDES.
GRANTS TO LOCAL AGENCIES. RIGHT
INCREASED ACTS FOR. UNDERSERVED
AT RISK YOUTH TO- TO PUBLIC
RECREATION ACTIVITIES. AND OF
COURSE WE HAVE OUR TWELVE STATE
CONSERVANCY THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD THAT DO A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES.
AND THAT INCLUDES BOTH THE-
ACTUAL MANAGEMENT OF LAND AS
WELL AS GRANTS TO. DIFFERENT
AGENCIES INVOLVED IN- IN
ACQUIRING OR CONSERVING PUBLIC
LANDS. IF YOU TURN THE PAGE FOR
ALL SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT THIS
WAS THE LEGISLATIVE BOND
MEASURE GENERAL OBLIGATION.
BOND THAT WAS APPROVED BY
VOTERS IN JUNE OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. YOU CAN SEE THE TABLE
HERE THAT THE BOND PROVIDING
TOTAL ABOUT FOUR POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS AND THAT
COVERED A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
NATURAL RESOURCES RELATED
PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES. AND IF
WE LOOK THROUGH IT IT LOOKS
LIKE ABOUT ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION OF THAT IS SPECIFIC TO
PARKS AND- PUBLIC LANDS
ACQUISITION AND MAINTENANCE OF
PUBLIC LANDS AND YOU CAN SEE
HERE ON THE TABLE THAT THE
SINGLE LARGEST SHARE OF THAT
JUST OVER A BILLION DOLLARS A
SPECIFIC TO IMPROVING. AND
EXPANDING LOCAL PARKS AND OF
THAT AMOUNT AT SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION WAS
SPECIFICALLY TO- PROVIDE GRANTS
TO PARK POOR COMMUNITIES AND
YOU CAN SEE HERE TOO WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF OTHER PROGRAMS
SUPPORTING STATE PARK'S
CONSERVANCY. AND OTHER PROGRAMS-
IMPORTANTLY YOU'LL SEE IN THE
TABLE TO THE ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION. ROUGHLY 90% OF THAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN APPROPRIATED
BY THE LEGISLATURE- THAT
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S BEEN SPENT
YET BUT IT'S BEEN APPROPRIATED
AND DEPARTMENTS ARE. HAVE
EITHER AWARDED THAT FUNDING TO
GRANT RECIPIENTS OR DEDICATED
TO PROJECTS OR IN THE PROCESS
OF DOING SO THAT A RELATIVELY
SMALL SHARE OF THAT LEFT. IF
YOU TURN TO PAGE FIVE- I WILL
GO THROUGH EACH ONE OF THESE
BULLET POINTS BUT I DID WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR THE COMMITTEE.
THEY'RE WORTH ARE HAVE BEEN AND
ARE SOME NOTABLE FISCAL
PROPOSALS RELATED TO PARKS AND
OPEN SPACE SO. IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET THAT WAS ENACTED THIS
PAST JUNE. WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IN
PARTICULAR EVEN EVEN YOU'LL
RECALL AT THE TIME THERE WAS
QUITE A BIT OF CONCERN GIVEN
THE PANDEMIC ABOUT THE STATE'S
FISCAL CONDITION- DESPITE THAT
THERE WAS SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND. APPROPRIATION PROVIDED TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT A STATE
PARKS AND OTHER PROGRAMS SO IT%
JUST HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE ONE WAS
THERE WAS QUITE A BIT CONCERNED
ABOUT. POTENTIAL LOST REVENUES
FOR STATE PARKS BECAUSE OF
REDUCED VISITOR SHIP AN
ACTIVITY- SO THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN BACK FILL
ANY LOST REVENUES- I BELIEVE
THE MOST RECENT UPDATE IS THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ANTICIPATE WE WON'T NEED THE
FULL ONE HUNDRED FIFTY IT MIGHT
BE MORE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY- ALTHOUGH
THAT'S NOT YET. FINAL IN
ADDITION THE CURRENT BUDGET
ALREADY ENACTED INCLUDED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT
EIGHTY TWO OH NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THE MOMENT- THIS
IS GRANTS TO PROVIDE.
UNDERSERVED YOUTH WITHOUT DOOR
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCES. AND
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS- TO
ESTABLISH A NEW STATE PARK-
THAT LOCATION THAT PARK. AND
NOT YET BEEN IDENTIFIED. I'M IN
IT THE- GUY HAS FOR. A NUMBER
NEW- FINDING FOR VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO PARKS AND
OPEN SPACE AND I JUST WANNA
HIGHLIGHT ONE IN PARTICULAR-
WHICH IS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
ONE BILLION DOLLAR WHILE FILER
FIRE RESILIENCY PACKAGE. THAT'S
IN FRONT OF THE LEGISLATURE NOW
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
PROPOSED FOR FOREST HEALTH.
ACTIVITIES TO- REDUCE THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT OF LAW I'LL
FIRED OWNERS ON OUR STATE LAND
SO THAT INCLUDES. EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT YOU SEE
HERE IN THE HAND OUT SPECIFIC
FOR STATE PARKS- BUT THERE'S
ALSO FUNDING FOR SIMILAR
ACTIVITIES. AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE- ALSO
STAYED ON THE LAND. AND OWNED
BY THE- A STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IN TALLINN
CONSERVANCY IS WELL SO THAT'S A
MAJOR NEW INVESTMENT I THINK A
RECOGNITION THAT THE STATE HAS
NOT INVESTED IN THOSE
ACTIVITIES ADEQUATELY IN PAST
YEARS. AND I'LL NOTE TO THAT-
POURTANT FEDERAL LEGISLATION
RECENTLY LAST YEAR THE FEDERAL
CONGRESSMEN AND PRESIDENTS
SIGNED- THE GREAT OUTDOORS ACT
WHICH PROVIDES- SORT OF LOCKS
IN A HUNDRED AND NINE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
STATE LOCAL AND FEDERAL PARKS
THE ANTICIPATION I BELIEVE IS
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL RE RECEIVE MAYBE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF AN ADDITIONAL
FOURTEEN OR SO MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. FROM THAT PROGRAM.
LASTLY IF YOU TURN TO PAGE SIX
OF THE HANDOUT JUST WANNA
IDENTIFY SOME OF THE SORT OF
FISCAL CHALLENGES THAT.
CONFRONT THE LEGISLATURE AS
YOU. CONSIDER THE DIFFERENT
ISSUES DIFFERENT CHALLENGES IN
PROVIDING ADEQUATE PARKING OPEN
SPACE- TO COMMUNITIES. THE
FIRST IS THAT WE KNOW EVEN WITH
OUR EXISTING LANDS- THAT. WE
HAVE CHALLENGES MANAGING THEM
THAT INCLUDES BOTH- FOR EXAMPLE
STATE PARKS AND FISH AND
WILDLIFE DEPARTMENTS HAVE
UNDERGONE WITH THEY'VE REFERRED
TO SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
ANALYSES TO IDENTIFY
DEFICIENCIES AND MEETING THEIR
EXISTING OBLIGATIONS. WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FOR EXAMPLE ON STATE
FACILITIES. AND IN ADDITION
YOU'VE HEARD SOME CONVERSATION
ALREADY ABOUT INCREASING RISKS
TO OUR EXISTING STATE LANDS DUE
TO CLIMATE CHANGE WEATHER
WILDFIRE SEALEVEL RISE OR
OTHER. CHALLENGES BUT IN
ADDITION TO THE CHALLENGES
MANAGING OUR EXISTING
FACILITIES AND OPEN SPACE THERE
ARE OF COURSE THE CHALLENGE HE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS
THIS MORNING ALREADY WHICH ARE
THE CHALLENGES OF. THE EXISTING
PARKS AND OPEN SPACES NOT
NECESSARILY BEING SUFFICIENT TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF ALL OF
CALIFORNIA THAT INCLUDES BOTH
THE- CONCERNS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED EARLIER ABOUT THE
DISPROPORTIONATE ACCESS THAT
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES HAVE
BASED ON GEOGRAPHY OR WEALTH OR
OTHER FACTORS- AS WELL AS-
CONCERN OR AN INTEREST IN
EXPANDING. THE SHARE OF THE
STATE LAND IN COASTAL WATERS
THAT ARE. CONCERNED FOR THE
FUTURE AND SO THAT. COURSE OF
REFLECT IN THE GULF EXECUTIVE
ORDER. TO INCREASE THOSE LANDS
TO THIRTY PERCENT- BY TWENTY
THIRTY. NOW WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE THINKING BOTH THE-
ABOUT THE- INVESTMENTS TO
BETTER PROTECT EXISTING LAN OR
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO PUBLIC
SPACE THERE ARE OF COURSE
FISCAL CONSTRAINTS AND SO JUST
TO IDENTIFY AS WE TALKED ABOUT-
ON THE FIRST PAGE THE STATE
FUNDING TYPICALLY COMES IN ONE
OF THREE. FLAVORS EITHER
GENERAL FIND STATE BOND FUNDS
OR SPECIAL FUNDS WHICH ARE
TYPICALLY FUNDED THROUGH FEE
PAYERS ARE TAXPAYERS AND EACH
ONE OF THOSE CAN BE USED TO YOU
CAN LOOK AT OPTIONS TO EXPAND
IN THE USE OF ANY OF THOSE FOR
STATE AND LOCAL PARKS- BUT EACH
COME WITH A DIFFERENT SET OF
TRADE OFFS TO BE AWARE OF-
GENERAL FUND OF COURSE- IS
ALWAYS. SOMETHING THAT- ANY
PROGRAM HAS TO ADJUST TO FIND
HAVE TO COMPETE FOR ESSENTIALLY
IN THE ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS
INCORPORATING NOW- MOST
RECENTLY BOTH OUR OFFICE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE
PROJECTED THAT THERE COULD BE
OUT YUR GENERAL FUND. DEFICIT
AND SO THAT CREATES A CHALLENGE
TO IDENTIFYING NEW FUNDING THAT
CAN BE USED TO EXPAND PROGRAMS
FROM THAT SOURCE- BOND FUNDS
LIKE PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT-
SOURCE THAT WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY USED IN THE STATE
TO SUPPORT- PARKS AND IN OTHER
PROJECTS THE- PROBABLY THE MAIN
THING TO JUST RECOGNIZE WITH
BOND FUNDS AS THOSE ARE ONE
TIME FUNDS. AND SO THAT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE FOR ACQUISITION OR
DEVELOPMENT OF FACILITIES BUT
IS NOT REALLY THE BEST USE- OR
OR THE BEST SOURCE. FOR ONGOING
OPERATIONAL COSTS. IN IN LASTLY
COURSE YOU CAN ALL LOOK AT ALL
OF FOR. SPECIAL FOR REVENUES
EITHER FROM FEEDS TAX- THE MAIN
TRADE OFF TO BE AWARE THERE IS
THOSE INCREASED REVENUES HAVE
TO BE ASSESSED ON SOMEONE
WHETHER THAT THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE VISITING THE PARKS OR-
OTHER SOURCES AND SO YOU IN.
CONCERNING THOSE TYPES OF
OPTIONS YOU ALWAYS GOING TO BE
COGNIZANT OF WHO WOULD BE
PAYING THOSE FEES IS IT
EQUITABLE IN AUTUMN HOW THOSE
FUNDS ARE USED- SO WITH THAT I
AM. HAPPY AT THE END OF THE
PANEL TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT. BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME
MEMBERS THAT WILL BE GOING IN
AND OUT GOING TO TAKE LIBERTY
THAT. ALLOWS SOME OF THE
MEMBERS TO MAYBE ASK YOU A
QUESTION OR TWO BEFORE THEY
HAVE TO CUT OUT. MEMBERS THANK
YOU MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GERMAN
GARCIA- MIGHT I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS ONE OF THEM IS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IT'S ON PAGE- IN FIVE.
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IT WAS THE FACT FIELD BECAUSE
THE PARKS WERE ANTICIPATED TO
HAVE LOWER REVENUE- AS A RESULT
OF COVERT YET COVERT DROVE MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE- TO GO OUTSIDE-
COULD YOU DESCRIBE WHERE THE
REVENUE LOSSES TOOK PLACE AND
WHERE THE REVENUE GAINS TOOK
PLACE IF MORE AND MORE PEOPLE
WERE. FREE INDUCING OR OR OR
FEE GENERATING- ASPECTS OF THE
PARKS. YES I THINK IT'S A
NUMBER IT'S A GOOD QUESTION AND
IT'S- SOMETHING THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT PEOPLE SPEAK TOO
WELL BUT I THINK THERE'S A FEW
DIFFERENT MOVING PIECES HERE
THAT EXPLAINS THE INTEREST.
RATE PART OF IT IS I MEAN SO I
THINK- SOME OF THE- LADIES THE
N. M. PARKS WERE CLOSED AND
WE'RE WE'RE MORE CLOSED EARLIER
IN THAT THIS PAST SPRING AND IN
THE SUMMER AND- THAT'S
OFTENTIMES SOME OF OUR HIGHEST
REVENUE GENERATING PERIODS. AND
SO THAT'S WHAT WE LOST SOME
REVENUE THERE PART OF IT TOO
HAS TO DO WITH THE TYPES OF
FACILITIES THAT WERE CLOSED SO-
FOR EXAMPLE I THINK MANY OF OUR
MUSEUMS ARE STILL CLOSED AND
THOSE ARE REVENUE. SOURCES FOR
US- THERE ARE ALSO- I THINK
OTHER ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE HAD
GENERATED LESS REVENUE
DEPENDING ON- YOU KNOW RENTALS
AND DIFFERENT TYPES OF THINGS
LIKE THAT AND THEN LASTLY I
THINK IT IS ACCORDING TO THE
CONVERSATION TO HAVE WITH THE
FARM IS WHERE VISITORS SHIFT
HAS HAPPENED THERE'S BEEN A
SHIFT IN SO. AND NOT ALL NOT
ALL PARTS CHANGED A CHARGE THE
SAME VISITOR ACCESS FEES AND SO
DEPENDING ON- WHERE PEOPLE ARE
ACCESSING THEY MAY THEY MAY
STILL BE VISITING IN GREATER
NUMBERS BUT IF IT'S IN
LOCATIONS THAT HAVE THAT
GENERATE LESS REVENUE FROM- THE
ACTUAL- FEASTED TO TOOK THE
PARKING FEES OR THE ENTRANCE
FEE. THAT COULD ACTUALLY
DIMINISH THANK YOU MY OTHER
QUESTION- FROM THERE THE
REFERENCE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
CALL AND YOU MAY OR MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO ANSWER THIS-
ESTABLISHED A GOAL OF
PROTECTING 30% OF THE STATE'S
LANDS BY TWENTY THIRTY- THAT'S
30% OF THE STATE OWNED PROPERTY
IS THAT WHAT THAT REFERENCE OR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S.
OVERALL PROPERTY PROTECTED. IN
SOME WAY DO YOU. YEAH I DON'T
KNOW IF IT. BEEN EXACT DEFINE
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
INTENTION IS 430% OF THE STATE
AND 30% OF COASTAL WATERS. TO
BE- PROTECTED OR CONSERVANCY-
WAY BUT WHAT WHAT PROTECTION
CONCERT MEANS TO I THINK ALSO I
HAVE NOT BEEN. FULLY DEFINED.
SO WE DON'T HAVE FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL. ANY
PROPOSALS TO SORT OF ENACT THAT
EXECUTIVE ORDER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER BROWN
WILL CONTINUE WITH THE NEXT
PRESENTATION. AND THEN WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM OTHER MEMBERS.
THANK YOU- CEDRIC MITCHELL
BRETT W. DIRECTOR FOR EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS THE WELCOME. THANK YOU
SIR- MY NAME IS ANDREA MITCHELL
I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AT
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS AND
TODAY I WILL BE SPEAKING ON THE
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT WE ADMINISTER
HERE PARKS FIRST I'LL GIVE YOU
A GENERAL DESCRIPTION OF THE
METHODOLOGY UTILIZED FOR
ENGAGING LOCAL STAFF
STAKEHOLDERS FOR ALL OUR
PROGRAMS I WILL THEN SHARE WITH
YOU THE STATUS OF SAID PROGRAMS
AND ANSWER IT AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
GENERALLY OUR APPROACH INCLUDES
FOCUS GROUPS. PUBLIC HEARINGS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WORKSHOPS
APPLICATION REVIEW AND AWARDS.
WHAT'S MORE DO WE HAVE A
DEDICATED TEAM TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IN THE COMPLETION OF THE
PROJECT AND TO ENSURE THE
PROJECT REMAINS- AND PUBLICLY
USED DURING THE DURATION OF THE
PERFORMANCE PERIOD. TO ENSURE
ACCESS BY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
WE IMPLEMENTED A ROBUST
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
AIMED AT SIMPLIFYING PROCESS
SEES. UPGRADING COMPUTER TOOLS
TO ENHANCE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION AND INSTITUTED AN
ONLINE APPLICATION SUBMITTAL
PROCESS. AIMED AT STREAMLINING
AND SEAMLESSLY PROVIDING
APPLICANTS WITH ACCESS TO TOOLS
THEY NEED TO. HAVE IN ORDER TO
SUBMIT A COMPETITIVE
APPLICATION. CORE TO OUR
PROGRAM IS A COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDE RESIDENTS ACCESS TO
PLANNING PROCESSES AND TO
REWARD APPLICANTS MUST SUBMIT
PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE. WE
DEVELOPED A PANDEMIC GUIDELINES
THAT VALUE VIRTUAL CONNECTIVITY
EQUALLY WITH IN PERSON
ENGAGEMENT. OUR COMMITMENT TO
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE HAS
INCREASED USING VIRTUAL
WORKSHOPS ONE ON ONE ACCESS
JUST TO NAME A FEW. EMAIL AND
PHONE CALLS OF A CERTAINLY A
PART OF THAT AND SPECIFIC
PROJECT OFFICERS HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED FOR EVERY REGION
WITHIN THE STATE. ALL
COMPETITIVE WORKSHOPS HAVE BEEN
RECORDED AND HAVE BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE ON THE TWENTY FOUR
HOUR BASIS. THE RECORD SESSIONS
HAVE BEEN SEGMENTED AND
CONTENTS TO ALLOW APPLICANTS TO
SELECT THEIR AREAS OF INTEREST
AND THE VIEW AND LISTEN TO
RECORDINGS IN ONE TO TEN MINUTE
SEGMENTS. DEPENDING ON THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE SUBJECT
MATTER. SO I'D LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU ABOUT THE STATUS OF
THE- PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE. A
COMPETITIVE PROGRAMS INCLUDE
THE STATEWIDE PARK AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
REVITALIZATION PROGRAM. AS
DIRECTOR INTERMENT MENTIONED WE
HAVE THREE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT WILL BE-
AWARDED THIS YEAR. THE
APPLICATIONS FOR THAT PROGRAM
ARE ACTUALLY DUE ON MARCH
TWELFTH. AT ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
SO JUST A REMINDER TO ALL OF
YOU OUT THERE MARCH TWELFTH AT
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE. THE STATE MY
PART PROGRAM APPLICATIONS WILL
BE DUE. WE ANTICIPATE THAT
WE'LL BE MAKING AWARDS IN
SEPTEMBER OCTOBER OF THIS YEAR.
AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE NOT AWARE
OF THIS PROGRAM. IT BASICALLY
PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY CREATE
NEW PARKS AND RECREATION
OPPORTUNITIES AND CRITICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. INCLUDES NEW PARKS
EXPANSION OF EXISTING PARKS FOR
THE REHABILITATION OF EXISTING
PARKS. THERE'S A THERE'S A
MAXIMUM GRANT UP EIGHT POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. AND THE
MINIMUM REQUEST OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS THERE IS NO
MATCH REQUIREMENT FOR THIS.
THIS PROGRAM IS ONE THAT'S-
HIGHLY SUBSCRIBED NORMALLY WE
RECEIVE ABOUT- ONE OUT OF EVERY
TEN APPLICATIONS WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO FIND. TO GIVE YOU AN
IDEA HISTORICALLY LAST ROUND WE
HAVE THREE HUNDRED AND FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
APPLICATIONS. ASKING FOR OVER
THREE BILLION DOLLARS- WE HAD-
OF THOSE FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
EIGHT APPLICATIONS. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WHAT'S
QUARTER PROGRAM IS COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT. AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. OTHER FOREIGN
SEVENTY EIGHT APPLICATIONS OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
AND OUR- OUR MOST UNDERSERVED
PARKOUR COMMUNITIES
PARTICIPATED IN THE PLANNING
AND DESIGN OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS. THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- CERTAINLY- OUR
PARTICIPATION IS HOW WE DEVELOP
APPLICATIONS AND PROJECTS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE TRANSFORMATIVE
FOR THE COMMUNITY CENTER THERE.
OUR CURRENT ROUND AS I SAID
WITH THE MARCH TWELFTH
DEADLINE- WE'VE CONDUCTED- TEN
APPLICATION WORKSHOPS IN JULY
AND AUGUST ATTENDED BY OVER A
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS. NOW
WE'RE CURRENTLY AVERAGING ABOUT
FORTY QUESTIONS PER DAY
REGARDING THIS PROGRAM SO WE
ANTICIPATE THAT IT WOULD BE
HIGHLY SUBSCRIBED ONCE AGAIN.
AGAIN THIS PROGRAM CREATES NEW
PARKS AND RECREATION
OPPORTUNITIES IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS SPECIFICALLY. HI IT HAS A
HISTORY OF BEING EXTREMELY-
SUBSCRIBE TO AND- WE ANTICIPATE
THAT THIS YEAR THAT WE WILL
BASED ON- THE FEEDBACK WE WERE
GETTING OUR HAVE AT LEAST A
SEVERAL HUNDRED APPLICATIONS
ARE LIKELY TO COME IN. FOR THIS
PROGRAM. THE REAL RECREATION
TOURISM PROGRAM. WE HAVE A
NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH DEADLINE FOR
THE APPLICATION WHEN TO SPEAK
BETTER WORDS WILL BE IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. OUR WORKSHOPS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED AND- THIS PROGRAM
WILL ALLOW FOR THOSE
APPLICATIONS. AND SHOULD YOU
NOT BE X. COMPETITIVE IN THE
STATE BY PARK PROGRAM TO STILL
APPLY FOR PROGRAMS IN. THAT
PARTICULAR PROGRAM. WE HAVE
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE AND ESSENTIALLY
ESSENTIALLY THE PROGRAM CREATES
AND EXPANDS ROLE RECREATION
OPPORTUNITIES- THE HEALTH. AND
COMMUNITIES OF THE TOWNS AND
THE TOWNS VISITORS. THE
REGIONAL PARK PROGRAM ALSO HAS
A NOVEMBER FIFTH DEADLINE. OUR
FOCUS GROUPS AND PUBLIC
HEARINGS AND GUIDELINE
APPLICATIONS HAVE ALL BEEN
COMPLETED THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE TO EXPAND AND IMPROVE
REGIONAL PARKS AGAIN THIS
TIMING WILL ALLOW FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE APPLIED
FOR GRANTS A MISTAKE BY PART
PROGRAM. IF THEY'RE NOT
SUCCESSFUL IN GAINING A
COMPETITIVE APPLICATION THEY
CAN'T COMPETE- FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM ALSO. OUR
PER CAPITA PROGRAM IS A NON
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM WE HAVE A
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE THOSE
ALLOCATIONS HAVE BEEN-
ANNOUNCED ON MINIMUM
ALLOCATIONS FOR COUNTIES AND
DISTRICTS IS FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. THE MINIMUM
ALLOCATIONS FOR CITIES- IS A
1-007-700-0950 TWO- WE HAVE
ENTERED INTO OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
CONTRACTS. WITH LOCAL PROVIDERS
THOSE CONTRACTS IN OUR CASE
ALLOW FOR US TO CELEBRATE A
ESSENTIALLY RESET UPDATE-
ACCOUNT WITH THE INDIVIDUALS
WITH THE INDIVIDUAL
JURISDICTIONS. AND THEN THEY
WILL SUBMIT APPLICATIONS TO US
FOR SPECIFIC PROJECTS AND WE
WILL ASSIST HIM ON FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THAT PROJECT
THROUGH THROUGH THE- COMPLETION.%
THE COMMERCE DEADLINE FOR THOSE
PROJECTS WILL BE JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE LIQUIDATION IS
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
YOUR MENTALITY- CAPITAL
PROGRAMS A SUB PROGRAM WITHIN
THE PER CAPITA PROGRAM. CITIES
AND DISTRICTS AND URBANIZED
COUNTIES WHERE THERE IS A
POPULATION OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND- IN THE COUNTY IN
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR LESS IN
POPULATION ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS PROGRAM- THE FINES. ARE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE- AND- IT'S
BASED ON THE ALLEGATIONS ARE
BASED ON THE AVAILABLE FUNDS IN
THE CAR. RECREATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND REVENUE
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM WE HAVE
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE FUNDS ARE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES BUT THAT CHANGED VOTER
APPROVAL FOR- EIGHT REVENUE
ENHANCEMENT MANAGER. BETWEEN
NOVEMBER FIRST OF TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN- AND NOVEMBER
THIRTIETH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
REVENUE ENHANCEMENT MEASURES
ESSENTIALLY ARE FEES OR TAXES
BUT THE SPECIFIC TO PARKS AND
RECREATION- AND DID NOT INCLUDE
OMNIBUS BILLS OR UNDER THIS-
TAX TEXAS DEMOCRATS. WHERE WE
ARE RIGHT NOW. YES ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS ARE IN LINE TO BE
ALLOCATED FOR PROP SIXTY EIGHT
WE HAVE- WE HAVE AGAIN
MAINTAINED A REQUIREMENT OF THE
PUBLIC BE ENGAGED IN THE
PROCESS SEES. BECAUSE THE
PROJECTS THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE- THAT WILL BE A WARNING WILL
BE LONG LIVED IN THE COMMUNITY
CENTER THERE. AT THIS TIME ALL
STOP FROM THOSE OF THE PROP
SIXTY EIGHT PROGRAMS AND IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME ALLOW FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU THE DIRECTOR WE
DEFINITELY HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
I'LL GO TO MY RIGHT- SOME
MEMBER RUBIO AND WORK MY WAY
BACK THIS WAY. THANK YOU FOR
THAT- SO I HAVE QUESTIONS YOU
SAID THAT YOU RECEIVED FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
APPLICATIONS OF THOSE HOW MANY
QUALIFIED IN. I ALSO HOW MANY
WERE REJECTED FOR
TECHNICALITIES WE HAVE- LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES THAT REALLY
CAN'T AFFORD A CONSULTANT TO
PREPARE THEIR APPLICATIONS SO-
THAT'S ALSO AN INTERESTING-
DATA THAT I THINK IS RELEVANT
BECAUSE IF SOME OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES CAN'T- FILE THE
APPLICATION OR THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES AND- AND ORDER
BEING REJECTED FOR
TECHNICALITIES ON THE
APPLICATIONS NOT NECESSARILY.
BECAUSE OF THEIR PROJECTS
THAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WE REPRESENT THOSE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES THAT MIGHT NEED
MORE ASSISTANCE YOU KNOW AND I
LOVE THAT YOU KNOW YOU'RE
GETTING FORTY QUESTIONS FOR PER
DAY THAT YOU'RE DOING ALL THESE
WORKSHOPS. BUT AGAIN YOU KNOW
SOME OF THOSE LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO APPLY
SOLD AGAIN THE QUESTION IS- HOW
MANY QUALIFIED OF THE FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT AND
NUMBER TWO HOW MANY WERE
REJECTED FOR TECHNICALITIES NOT
FOR. PROJECTS- CERTAINLY SOME
OF THE FOURTEEN SEVENTY
APPLICATIONS ALL WERE WERE
ELIGIBLE AND THEY- WERE- IF YOU
REJECTED ON ANY TECHNICALITIES.
IT'S OUR POLICY THAT WE NOT
REJECT APPLICATIONS BASED ON
TECHNICALITY IN FACT. ONCE WE
RECEIVE THE APPLICATIONS WHAT
WE DO. IS THAT THEY ARE MISSING
ITEMS WE CONTACT THE AGENCIES
AND GIVE THEM AN APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT OF TIME TO- TO PROVIDE
THAT. EQUALLY ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE DO IS TO ENSURE THAT
APPLICATIONS ARE APPLICANTS ARE
ABLE TO PUT IN A QUALIFIED
APPLICATION. WE HAVE A SERIES
OF WORKSHOPS IN THIS CASE FOR
THIS YEAR WE HAD TEN. IN THE
PAST WE HAD- AN ADDITIONAL-
SIXTEEN- BUT WHAT WE DO AT
THOSE APPLICATION WORKSHOPS AS
WE GO THROUGH PAGE BY PAGE. I'M
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS MAY HAVE. WEEKLY TO
FIND WHAT IS NEEDED. AND THEN
WE PROVIDE A PROJECT OFFICER
THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO. BUT
THEY CAN CONTACT THROUGHOUT THE
APPLICATION PROCESS TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
HAVE THEIR QUESTIONS ANSWERED.
IN THIS CASE FOR THIS ROUND. WE
HAD A NINE MONTH PROCESS
NORMALLY AT SIX MONTHS. BUT
BECAUSE WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
COVERAGE. WE WANT TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
GIVE APPLICANTS. THE TOWN THEY
NEED IN ORDER TO CONTACT AND
ENGAGE THE PUBLIC. INPUT IN THE
PLANNING PROCESS. SO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION- WE DON'T
DISQUALIFY FOR TECHNICAL
REASONS OUR GOAL IS TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT COMMUNITIES ARE
SIR WE RECOGNIZE THAT-
COMMUNITIES HAVE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF SOPHISTICATION AND
PUTTING IN APPLICATIONS SO WE
WILL LOOK AT THE APPLICATION
FOR THEM. AS THE DESERT AS
YOU'RE MOVING FORWARD- WE DON'T
REQUIRE THAT ALL OF THE
APPLICATION BE COMPLETED AT THE
TIME OF SUBMITTAL GOTTEN SUCH A
SEQUEL- THINGS SUCH AS-
MEETINGS BY. BE A OFFICIALS ARE
ELECTED BOARDS- WE ALLOW FOR
THOSE BILLS TO COME IN LATER.
SO THE GOAL HERE IS NOT TO
DISQUALIFY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT THESE
PROJECTS AND CERTAIN PEOPLE THE
BEST POSSIBLE WAY THAT WE CAN.
SO UNLIKE OTHER PROJECTS OR
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT YOU MAY BE
AWARE OF. WELL WE DON'T REQUIRE
LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION WHAT
WE REQUIRE IS COMMUNITY ENGAGE
PROCESS. THAT ALLOWS FOR US TO
SEE. WHERE THE PUBLIC IS GOING
IN AND THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
PARTICULAR PROJECT. DOES THAT
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION. THANK YOU
YES IT DOES- BUT I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET A BREAKDOWN
OF THOSE APPLICATIONS THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE TOO DETAILED
BY YOU KNOW I'M SURE YOU HAVE A
BREAK DOWN THAT THE COMMITTEE
COULD. COULD LOOK OVER LIKE I
SAID MY CONCERN AND I
APPRECIATE THE EXPLANATION AND
I COMMEND YOU FOR A LOT OF WORK
THAT YOU DO HOWEVER IF WE CAN
GIVE US A BREAK DOWN OF THE
APPLICATION SO THAT WE CAN. YOU
KNOW SEE AND PERHAPS- WERE ABLE
TO HELP IN OTHER AREAS- BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE EFFORT
THAT YOU GUYS ARE PUTTING INTO
MAKING SURE THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES QUALIFY FOR THESE
APPS FOR IT FOR THESE THESE
FUNDS THANK YOU. OR WHAT LET'S
PROVIDE REGION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR SURE- MR MITCHELL
THANK YOU FOR THE-
PRESENTATION. AND I AM THINKING
OF THE FOLLOW UP KIND OF. ON
THE APPLICATION PROCESS IS GOOD
TO HEAR THAT YOU HELP BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW THAT I GUESS I DON'T
CALL IT SUCCESS BIAS ONCE. YOU
HAVE CERTAIN ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT ARE SUCCESSFUL THEY TEND
TO- HAVE GREATER SUCCESS THAN
THOSE THAT HAVEN'T HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY- MORE CHALLENGES
SPECIAL INCOME TO COMPETITIVE
GRANTS. SO EVEN IF. THEN
SCENARIOS YOU'RE MAKING SURE
THAT EVERYONE HAS THEIR- THE
PROPER APPLICATION PUT IN
PLACE. HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT. YOU KNOW IT'S ONE THING
TO PUT A COMPETITIVE GRANT OUT
THERE. AND. HI FOLKS APPLY BUT
IS THERE ANY. I MEETING WITH
WITH INTEREST. ARE EITHER KNOW%
HOW WE- YOU I GO ABOUT IT BUT-
TO BE PROACTIVE IN IDENTIFYING-
AREAS THAT THAT ARE PART DOES
THEIRS OR MAY NEED ASSISTANCE
AND MAYBE THERE HASN'T BEEN-
NECESSARILY. OF A GRANT
APPLICATION BUT IS THERE A
PROCESS WHERE EVEN WE COULD.
YOU KNOW HELP OUR CITIES DO IT
OUR COUNTIES DO IT OUR PARTS
DEPARTMENTS WHATEVER IT MIGHT
BE BUT- IT JUST SEEMS LIKE-
SOMETIMES. IT TAKES A LONG TIME
TO GET. THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
BARRIERS MEAN THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT COST AN EARLIER PANEL-
BUT IT TAKES A LONG TIME TO GET
SOME OF THESE- PARTICULAR
PROJECTS APPROVED BUT- I'M-
BEYOND THAT IN TERMS OF THE
APPLICATION. PROCESS I'D I'D
REFERRED EARLIER TO THE FACT OF
YOU KNOW BEING IN A HIGH COST
OF LIVING AREA. HI PROPERTY
VALUE AREA IT SEEMS A SOMETIMES
DISADVANTAGE SOME OF- OF THE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN MY DISTRICT.
THAT AREN'T THAT DO HAVE PARKED
OFFICES BUT BECAUSE- OF THE
EQUATIONS AND CALCULATIONS
USED. IT'S SOMETIMES HARD
AGAINST AND THEY HAPPEN TO LIVE
IN A HIGH CLASS LIVING AREA- IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT. IS YOU CAN
OR HAS BEEN ACCOUNTED FOR A CAN
BE ACCOUNTED FOR. GOING FORWARD
I KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT TO GET TO
THAT LEVEL OF SPECIFICITY WHEN
YOU HAVE. A STATEWIDE PROGRAM
BUT IS THERE A WAY THAT WE CAN
ACCOUNT FOR THAT SO THAT WE GET
THE REAL. THE REAL TIME NEED.
OF THE FAMILIES IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. CERTAINLY I'M AND
THAT'S IT YOU BRING IT BACK
POINT- OF THE THINGS THAT WE DO
IS WE DEVELOPED ANY COMMITTEE
FACTFINDER IS A TOOL THAT
ALLOWS FOR US TO IDENTIFY- TO
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OUR PRODUCTS
ARE AND WHERE THEY'RE NOT- WE
ALSO HAVE TOOLS THAT ALLOW FOR
US TO IDENTIFY- MAP OUT THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WHERE THOSE THOSE THOSE PARK
OUR DEFICITS ARE. EQUALLY ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO MR ARBITRATION
PROCESS WHICH WE PROVIDE- WHICH
IN THE CASE OF STATEWIDE PART
PROGRAM INVOLVED OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED PEOPLE ENGAGED ON IT
AND POUNDING ON THE ON THE-
GUIDELINES BUT IT GIVES US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE OUR
CHRISTIAN COMMUNITIES TOWARD
IDENTIFYING WHICH REALLY. NEEDS
SPACES IN OUR COMMUNITIES. I
FILE INCOME IS A QUALIFYING ACT
AND CARPARK ACREAGE IS A
QUALIFIER. OUR APPLICATIONS ARE
DESIGNED TO LAST FOR YOUR STORE
TO BE TOLD AND TO BE TOLD
THROUGH THE EYES. AND EARS OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING
THERE. SO SO UNLIKE MANY
PROGRAMS WE DO ACTUALLY CARE
ABOUT THE DETAILS AND MOVE DOWN
TO THE NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL. THE
COMPUTER TOOLS HAVE HELPED US
TO DO THAT IT HELPS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WOULD
NORMALLY WOULD TAKE DAYS IF NOT
WEEKS TO ACCOMPLISH. MUCH IN
SECONDS IDENTIFYING WHERE THOSE
THOSE- DEFICITS REALLY PART. ON
WHETHER IT'S IN SAN JOSE OR
WHETHER IT'S IN LOS ANGELES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. IF YOU LOOK
AT THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL THEY RANGE FROM
THE SMALL COMMUNITIES OF
AMERICA. TO DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES WELL THEY RANGE FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO THE- FOR
THE MOST PART OF OUR STATE. AND
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE COMPLETE
APPLICATION PROCESS THAT WE GO
THROUGH. WE ALSO DON'T JUST
PLAY PAPER REVIEWS WE GET
OUTLOOK TO THE COMMUNITIES. WE
SEE THE PROJECT SITES WE MEET
WITH PARKS AND THEN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
COMMUNITY'S NEEDS ARE REALLY
GOING TO BE- SO IT'S NOT JUST A
PAPER REVIEW. IT'S GETTING A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
COMMUNITY'S NEEDS AND THE
STATE'S NAMES AND DIVERSITY. OF
OUR STATE AND WHAT NEEDS TO
OCCUR. THEY PROCESS THE WE DID
A LITTLE AT OR SO. HAS REALLY
GREAT IT'S BILL TO- AND EVEN
SOME- I DID SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN DONE BASED UPON. YEARS OF
TRIAL AND ERROR. AND WHEN YOU
LOOK BACK AT THE STATEWIDE
PROGRAM SEMI PART PROGRAM
PARTICULAR WHAT WE SEE IS WE
SEE. THE ABILITY- TO ACTUALLY-
COURAGE- ENCOURAGED ME THE
NEIGHBORHOOD YES OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD- COMMUNICATION TO
TAKE PLACE SO I WE PRODUCED A
DOCUMENT IT'S ON OUR WEBSITE
IT'S PLANNING- PART PLANNING
AND DESIGN THROUGH THE USE OF
COMMUNITY AND THAT'S THE ONE IN
WHICH- HAS BEEN APPROVALS BASED
ON OVER TWELVE HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS IN ABOUT FIFTEEN
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE SO WE HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. WHAT WE'RE
ALSO FINDING IS THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO FIND THOSE POCKETS IN URBAN
AREAS AS WELL AS IN. OTHER
RURAL COMMUNITIES AROUND THE
STATE. AND IT'S ABOUT A GOOD
PROCESS NOT JUST LOOKING AT ONE
IN PARTICULAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT LOOK
FORWARD TO THE- DOING A DEEPER
DIVE AS TO THE PROCESS BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE THEY'RE DEFINITELY
TAKING THESE THINGS INTO
ACCOUNT AND THERE'S NOT THERE'S
NEVER A PERFECT PROCESS BUT WE
HAVE TO KEEP ON BECAUSE
IMPROVING AS WE LEARN MORE MORE
SO. THANK YOU. A DIRECTOR-
MITCHELL THANK YOU SO MUCH- YOU
BOMB. DEFINITELY BEEN-
PROVIDING SOME GOOD
INFORMATION- ALONG THE WAY FOR
THOSE WHO ARE APPLYING. FOR
THESE GRANTS I KNOW FIRSTHAND
MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES IN OUR
DISTRICT. HAVE HAD A GOOD-
OPEN- COMMUNICATION WITH WITH
YOU IN THE AGENCY. PRIOR TO
APPLYING AND EVEN AFTER
APPLYING I I'VE ALWAYS
ENCOURAGED THE CITY'S
APPLICANTS TO FOLLOW UP WITH
THE STATE. THE STATE AGENCY AND
GET THE FEEDBACK AT THE HONEST
FEEDBACK IN TERMS OF WHERE THE
APPLICATION PUBLICATION. FOR
PURPOSES OF YOU KNOW SHARPENING
YOUR PENCIL AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE NEXT ROUND IS MORE
COMPETITIVE FOR THEM AND YOU IF
YOU'VE ALWAYS DONE THAT YOUR
TEAM IS ALWAYS ON THAT I WANT
TO COMMEND YOU FOR THAT I KNOW.
THEY'RE STILL QUESTIONS ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS WE HAD AND YOU'VE
ANSWERED THAT IN TERMS OF THE
PER CAPITA FUNDING FUNDING THAT
EVERY CITY AND COUNTY JUST
AUTOMATICALLY GETS FROM PROP
SIXTY EIGHT. THERE ARE MANY-
AGENCIES THAT ARE STILL UNAWARE
OF THAT FUNDING YOU MENTIONED
COUNTIES FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CITIES A HUNDRED SEVEN SEVEN
THOUSAND. THAT THAT'S A SHADE
STRUCTURE OVER PLAYGROUND
THAT'S A WATER FEATURE IN A HOT
AREA OF THE STATE THAT'S A-
PERHAPS EVEN FABRICATED NEW
RESTROOMS I MEAN THAT THAT'S
MONEY THAT CAN GO A LONG WAY.
WHAT ARE THE- COMMUNICATIONS
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE AS-
FOR INFORMING THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES- IT'S LIKE A YOU HAVE
SOME MONEY RIGHT HERE YOU JUST
NEED TO SUBMIT A PROJECT- WE'RE
GONNA REVIEW IT. AND TELL YOU
YEA OR NAY OR MAKE SOME
MODIFICATIONS OR WHAT WHAT ARE
YOU ALL DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE AGENCIES KNOW THAT
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME COMMUNITIES EVEN IN OUR
DISTRICT THAT ARE STILL. IN
THE- GONNA NOT KNOWING- PHASE.
OF HOW TO ACCESS THESE DOLLARS.
CERTAIN WE'VE BEEN NOTIFIED
EVERY AGENCY THAT THAT'S
QUALIFIED FOR THE GRANT FUNDS-
WE'VE ENTERED INTO CONTRACTS
WITH MOST OF THEM- IF NOT ALL
OF THEM AT THIS PARTICULAR
POINT- SOME OF THE
COMMUNICATION MAY BE INTERNAL
AND THAT- IT JUST NOT AWARE
THAT THE THAT THE DOLLARS ARE
AVAILABLE BUT THEY HAVE- BUT
EVERY INSTITUTION EVERY AND
EVERY- JURISDICTION HAS BEEN
NOTIFIED AND WE HAVE HAD DIRECT
CONTACT WITH A PROJECTOFFICER-
TO THAT JURISDICTION SO- WE
WOULD BE GLAD TO TALK TO
WHOMEVER YOU YOU'VE- COME
ACROSS THAT ARE NOT AWARE THAT
THE DOLLARS HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED OR- ALLOCATED TO
THEIR JURISDICTIONS. BUT BUT
TYPICALLY WE HAVE MADE PERSONAL
CONTACT AS WELL AS- WRITTEN
CONTACT AND WE ALSO HAD A
MANDATORY WORKSHOPS WHICH WHICH
WAS ATTENDED BY OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS- GOING OVER
ALL THE MONEY CAN BE SPENT ON
THE PROCESS FOR SECURING IT-
THEIR ALLOCATIONS ALL OF THAT
HAS BEEN DONE IN THE LAST.
WEEKS AND- SO IT'S SURPRISING
TO ME THAT IF THEY'RE NOT
AWARE- BUT IT IS OUT THERE AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO TALK TO THE
MEMBER- WE KEEP USING IT YES
SIR ONE THING WILL DO AND WE
HAVE EVERY EVERY THREE TO SIX
MONTHS WE HAVE AGENCY REVIEWS
AND WE REMIND FOLKS OF ALL THE
MONEY THAT THEY HAVE AVAILABLE
WE SEEK OUT THE STATUS OF
PROJECTS TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
THEY ARE MOVING FORWARD SO-
SOMETIMES THERE'S A CHANGEOVER
IN STAFF AND PERHAPS THAT
DIDN'T GET COMMUNICATED BUT WE-
STAND PERSONAL CONTACT WITH.
EACH OF OUR CUSTOMERS TO ENSURE
THE THING THAT. THEY DID NOT
LEAVE MONEY ON THE TABLE. SO
WE'RE GONNA CARRY JOB ALL A OF
MIKE- KIND OF PUT OUT A NOTICE
IN THERE COME AND- FOR THOSE
COMING THAT ARE NOT AWARE THAT-
THEY BE CONTACTING YOU. AND OR
VICE VERSA- BECAUSE THAT'S
MONEY THAT AS YOU SAID IS ON
THE TABLE AND IF THOSE
CONTRACTS AREN'T. ALREADY IN
PLACE WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING
THAT WE CAN GET THAT MONEY OUT-
I WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT THAT
D. DEFICIENCIES- FUNDING. AS IT
RELATES TO A. B. R. THIRTY ONE
CRITERIA THAT ARE USED FOR
DISHING OUT SOME OF THESE
DOLLARS FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. HE TALKED TO US
ABOUT YOU KNOW PROJECTS THAT
YOU'VE SEEN THAT PERHAPS- COULD
USE OR REQUIRE. ADDITIONAL I
DON'T KNOW LEGISLATIVE-
CRITERIA MODIFICATIONS WE HEARD
SOME SUGGESTIONS EARLIER TO BE-
THAT MUCH MORE INTENTIONAL WHEN
IT COMES TO- GETTING DOLLARS
TO- POR PART COMMUNITIES THAT
MAY FIND THEMSELVES IN. REGIONS
OF THE STATE THAT THE- THE
SOCIO ECONOMICS ARE ARE NOT. IN
LINE WITH THE POOR PARK
COMMUNITY CIRCUMSTANCES DO YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS OR OPINIONS
ON HOW THAT- GREAT YEARS BEEN
WORKING AS RELATES TO THE A. B.
THIRTY ONE. OUR STATE PARK
PROGRAM. WELL THIS AS A. B.
THIRTY ONE'S CONCERN AND THAT
AND THE WAY IN WHICH WE- ARE
ENGAGING- WE'VE SEEN OUR
PROJECTS COME FROM VERY RURAL
COMMUNITIES LIKE EARLY MARCH
AND CENTRAL VALLEY. TO TO
PROJECTS IN CORNING AND STOPPED
AND THE NORTH VALLEY TO
PROGRESS IN CALEXICO I MEAN
THERE IS A- WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A-
POINT OF CONTACT. THAT
INDIVIDUAL'S RESPONSIBILITY IS
TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE-
TALKING AND ANSWERING QUESTIONS
SPECIFIC TO THE REGIONS THAT
THERE'S OTHER THINGS EQUALLY.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO ALSO
AND PRIOR TO. OCTOBER NINETEEN
BUT WE SPENT A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME HAVING-
WORKSHOPS IN REGIONS- IN AREAS-
AND HAVING THOSE WORKSHOPS IN
PERSON. I WOULD CALL THE
NINETEEN THAT CERTAINLY HASN'T
BEEN THE CASE BUT WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO. THROUGH THE
USE OF VIDEO. IS HONESTLY A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN THE
NUMBERS THAT HAVE BEEN THERE ON
AVERAGE WE WERE SEEING ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED PARTICIPANTS
CONTOUR WORKSHOPS. WHICH FOR
OUR WORKSHOPS THAT TAKE YOU
THROUGH EVERY DETAIL OF THE
PROGRAM. TOO OFTEN NEARLY
TWELVE HUNDRED. I HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN THIS ROUND
THROUGH OUR UTILIZING. THE
SYSTEM IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN-
HOW MANY APPLICATIONS WILL COME
IN FOR THIS ROUND- WE AS I SAID
HAVE A DEADLINE OF THE TWELFTH
OF. THIS MONTH- BUT WE
ANTICIPATE THAT IT THAT THOSE
NUMBERS WILL BE SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER BASED ON THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
HAPPENING. BETWEEN OUR PROJECT.
OFFICERS AND THE PUBLIC. THANK
YOU GOD MITCHELL CAN YOU JUST
IN CLOSE- GOAL OVER- THE MONEY
THAT'S ON THE TABLE I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED IT ALREADY BUT I GOT
A NOTE RIGHT HERE IN SECONDS
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW HOW MUCH
MONEY IS. AVAILABLE- YOU MANAGE
IN YOUR- HOW- OVER SIX. IT WAS.
AND IT REALLY IT US YOU KNOW
TAKE A WE THAT. WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO FUND THE SPA- FOR
PART DEVELOP PARKING IN WITH
THE FOCAL POINT BEING THE THESE
PARKER ARE WE UNDER. SIXTY PER.
OF COMMUNITIES ARE STATE OF THE
STATE- ARE FALLING UNDER THAT
CRITERIA SO CAN YOU JUST KIND
OF RECAP THE MONIES THAT ARE ON
THE TABLE THEY'RE GOING OUT YOU
MENTIONED THE DATE DEADLINES-
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
FOLKS THAT ARE WATCHING RIGHT
NOW THEY WANT TO READ- HERE
TAKE THE TECHNOLOGY OF THAT US
OF. FLOOR IS YOURS. STARTING
WITH THE STATEWIDE PARK PROGRAM
WHICH HAS THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
WITH APPLICATIONS DUE ON MARCH
THE TWELFTH. OF THIS YEAR WE
ANTICIPATE AWARDS BEING.
ANNOUNCED IN SEPTEMBER OCTOBER
OF THIS YEAR. WE HAVE. OUR
URBAN PARK- THE- RULE
RECREATION AND TOURISM PROGRAM
WHICH IS A TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM APPLICATION
DEADLINE FOR THAT PROGRAM WILL
BE ON NOVEMBER FIFTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE HAVE THE
REGIONAL PARK PROGRAM WHICH IS
ANOTHER TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM. WITH EIGHT
NOVEMBER FIFTH APPLICATION
DEADLINE. WE HAVE THE PER
CAPITA PROGRAM WHICH IS A NON
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM WITH A
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE. WE HAVE THE
URBAN COUNTY PER CAPITA PROGRAM
AT THIRTEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE THE ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS FOR THOSE TWO
PROGRAMS ARE ANNOUNCED ON OUR
WEBSITE. SCANS THE AMOUNTS THAT
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR OUR
ANNOUNCED AND POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE. WE HAVE THE RECREATION
INFRASTRUCTURE REVENUE
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS A
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM. WHICH WE ALSO HAVE ALL
OF THE ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS-
LISTED ON OUR WEBSITE- THE
COVERAGE PERIOD FOR THOSE
DOLLARS IS DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH LIQUIDATION
EXTENDING THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. WE GLAD TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH ANY QUESTIONS OR SIMPLY TO
CONTACT OUR OFFICE OR THROUGH
OUR WEBSITE. A LIST OF PROJECT
OFFICERS SPECIFIC TO THE
REGIONS ARE AS LISTED BY COUNTY-
EQUALITY- I'M AVAILABLE AS IS
ALL OF MY STAFF TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ANYONE MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR KNOW WHAT
LET'S JUST ONE REQUEST FROM YOU
THAT INFORMATION WILL BE
SIGNIFICANTLY VALUABLE WILL
HELP DISSEMINATE THAT TO OUR
COLLEAGUES ONE THING THAT. MANY
COLLEAGUES ARE ALWAYS ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS- THE
NOTIFICATION TO- THEIR OFFICES
AS YOUR- MAKING AWARD
ANNOUNCEMENTS ANTI WANTING TO
COORDINATE WITH THE STATE
AGENCY A LITTLE BETTER- TO
REALLY CELEBRATE THE THESE-
AWARDS THAT ARE COMING TO THE
DISTRICT IT'S A REQUEST IT'S A-
IT'S AN ASK THAT THAT I'M
MAKING THIS SEE IF THERE'S
BETTER. WAYS TO COMMUNICATE
THAT TO- LEGISLATIVE OFFICES
WOULD BE ASSEMBLY THE SENATE-
WHAT HAVE YOU BUT DEFINITELY
WANT TO PARTICIPATE WITH THE
RENTALS ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE BEING
MADE. IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY-
WITH THAT I DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS I WANT TO THANK
YOU AND MISTER BROWN. FOR
PRESENTING WITH US TODAY WE DO
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
COME IN FROM- COLLEAGUES THAT
ARE NOT HERE FOR THE LA ALL
WILL SEND THOSE OVER- FOR
RESPONSES RELATED TO
INVESTMENTS IMPACTS ON.
DEPARTMENT AS IT RELATES TO
CLIMATE- PRINTING FIRES AND
THINGS OF THAT SORT BUT- WILL
DEFINITELY GET THOSE TOMB-
CLEARLY THE INTERESTS THAT SEEM
TO BE HERE THE PARKS- IMPROV
SIXTY EIGHT INVESTMENTS. SO
WITH THAT- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT A PANEL AGAIN I
THINK THE- PANELISTS ON THE
SECOND- PRESENTATION I'M GOING
TO ALSO JUST NOTE. FOR THOSE IN
THE PUBLIC THAT WANT TO CALL
IN- WE WANT TO JUST LET YOU
KNOW THAT THE CALLING NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. FOR THOSE WHO
WANT TO CALL IN DURING THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS THAT WILL TAKE
PLACE RIGHT AFTER THIS THE
THIRD AND FINAL- PANEL THAT WE
HAVE- WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
FUTURE NEEDS WE HAVE ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY MINUTES TO
ATTACK WITH THIS ISSUE I THINK
THAT'S PLENTY OF TIME. TO DO SO
WE HAVE THE FIRST A PRESENTER
WILL BE BLEND OF AUSTIN AS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF NATURE
FOR ALL WE HAVE MARKET. ONLY
VICE PRESIDENT VISITED PAIRS OF
PA A POLICY FOR CAL. WATER FELL.
AND KILLING ONE. LOWER
PRESIDENT OF CEO. CAL SO WITH
THAT- I'LL- GIVE THE MICROPHONE
AND THE ATTENTION TO BELINDA
FOSTER EMAILS WELCOME GOOD TO
SEE YOU AND OTHER FORAGERS.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH JERRY
GARCIA IT'S MY GREAT PLEASURE
TO BE WITH YOU HERE TODAY AND
ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE ALL THIS IS JUST AN
UNPRECEDENTED OPPORTUNITY THAT
WE HAVE AND IT'S OBVIOUSLY HARD
TO FOLLOW THE MONEY GUYS YOU
KNOW AND- APPRECIATE ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT CEDRIC AND
STAFF. I WAS ABLE TO SHARE
ABOUT- YOU KNOW THE
OPPORTUNITIES IT WE ALL HAVE
WITH EXISTING IN STATE FUNDS
ARE TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
EQUITY NEEDS FOR PARKS I
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE BY THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. ARE
REGARDING THE TREMENDOUS NEED
THAT THERE IS OUT THERE FOR
PARKS AND- I JUST OBVIOUSLY
WITH CODED WE'VE SEEN THAT
DON'T REALLY ASSUME IN QUITE A
BIT MORE IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT
NEED IS AND FRANKLY WHAT I'M
HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT IS
THAT. YOU KNOW WE HAVE- PEOPLE
OF COLOR IN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE SUFFERED FROM
DISINVESTMENT AND CHALLENGES
FOR DECADES ALL THE TIME
FRANKLY BEEN KIND OF THE
BACKBONE OF SUPPORTING. EFFORTS
TO PASS BONDS FOR THE LAST TWO
TO THREE DECADES AND YET HAVE
NOT SEEN THOSEFUNDS BE
INVESTED IN THEIR COMMUNITIES-
MAYBE YOU KNOW IT'S IMPROVING A
LITTLE BIT I THINK IN THE LAST
TEN YEARS- DUE TO THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE- SOME GREAT ELECTED
MEMBERS. IN THE ASSEMBLY AND AT
OTHER LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT THAT
RECOGNIZE THESE ISSUES AND ARE
PROVIDING FOR VEHICLES TO
INVEST IN IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR- THAT HAVE THESE
CHALLENGES- BUT I CAN TELL YOU
FROM WHERE- I'VE DONE THIS WORK
FOR YOU KNOW OVER FORTY YEARS
SAID BECAUSE I'M OLD. AND I
DON'T GIVE UP AND I THINK THAT
THE YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
ORGANIZATIONS STATEWIDE- THAT
ARE VERY COMMITTED TO THESE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH COMMUNITY FOR A LONG TIME
TO. MAKE SURE THAT NOT ONLY
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO LOCAL PARKS
BUT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
STATE AND FEDERAL PUBLIC LANDS
AND SO WHAT I'M GOING TO FOCUS
ON TODAY IS THE ISSUE OF THOSE
ACCESS PROGRAMS AND SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES AND SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT I SEE COMING
UP. SO. I'M GOING TO GO THROUGH
A QUICK LITTLE- SLIDESHOW HERE
THAT I HOPE. ALL IS NOT GONNA
BE DESTROY. BY THE IT'LL HELP
US KEEP ON- EARLIER WE- A
LITTLE. SIMPLE ABOUT PEOPLE'S
PERCEPTIONS OF YOU KNOW WHY
THEY NEEDED ACCESS TO NATURAL
LANDS. I'LL JUST SHARE THIS
REALLY QUICK QUOTE THAT. WAS
PICKED UP ACTUALLY- IN THE
PRESS LAST WEEK- AND IT'S FROM
ONE OF OUR COMMUNITY LEADERS- A
VOLUNTEER WITH NATURE FOR ALL.
WHO MEET ANGLES LHASA WHO SAID
WHEN FAMILIES VISIT THE SAME
GABLE MOUNTAINS THEY TRANSFORM.
BECOMING MORE RELAXED AND
EXCITED TO EXPLORE AND
EXPERIENCE NATURE. IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT THIS
NATURAL RESOURCE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO ENJOY. AND THAT
TO ME SAYS IT ALL RIGHT AND
IT'S ABOUT YOU KNOW MAKING SURE
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT NORMALLY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
PUBLIC LANDS- THAT THEY HAVE
LIKELY VOTED TO PROTECT. I'LL
GET THAT OPPORTUNITY- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT NATURE FOR ALL
WORKS ON HE IS- JUST A BASELINE
POLICY OBJECTIVES THAT WE HAVE.
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO ALL THOSE
BENEFITS. ARE THE NATURE CAN
PROVIDE AND I HAVE TO GIVE A
BIG SHOUT OUT TO TWO OF MY
STAFF MEMBERS OR OR A VERY
SMALL A LOCAL NONPROFIT- BUT I
HAVE BRAND MATSUMOTO WHO IS OUR
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE SAME
PEOPLE MOUNTAINS. OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM WHO IS JUST DOING A
BANG UP JOB. AND A STEADY AT
NANDO'S WHO- IS OUR COMMUNITY
TRANSIT SENIOR ORGANIZER. AND
THEY HAVE BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY
FOCUSED ON THIS ISSUE AND-
WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE. BETTER SERVICES TO
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES. OUR
ORGANIZATION WORKS ON
PROTECTING PUBLIC LANDS
CREATING MORE NATURAL OPEN
SPACES AND- ALL THE SUBJECT
MATTER TODAY CONNECTING PEOPLE.
TO- TO PUBLIC LANDS. WE WERE.
WHEN NO WERE JUST TO ON THIS-
WITH. ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT
CAME ABOUT IN PARTICULAR IN LA
COUNTY RELATED TO OUR MEASURE
M. WHICH PROVIDED A FUNDING
RESOURCE FOR TRANSIT OUR
PROGRAMS. ON MEASURE A WHICH
NORMATIVE AND SO ELOQUENTLY-
AND THEN W. WHICH IS EIGHTY
EIGHT FUNDING MEASURE UP FOR
SAFE CLEAN WATER. THAT WE HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
LEVERAGE IT AND AGAIN WAS VERY
FORTUNATE HERE IN LA COUNTY
THAT WE HAVE ELECTRIC OVER THE
COURSE OF. A VOTE TWO VOTES-
THAT PASSED MEASURES THAT ARE
GENERATING ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR WHICH IS
JUST A PHENOMENAL OPPORTUNITY
ON TOP OF YOU KNOW WHAT. IS
AVAILABLE AT THE STATE LEVEL.
AND WHAT WE WANNA DO IS
MAXIMIZE THOSE INVESTMENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY LEVERAGING OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE THE MOST
AT DISADVANTAGE. ALL WE
RECOGNIZE AND IN PARTICULAR FOR
THE ACCESS PROGRAMS WE HAD TO
HAVE A PLAN. FOR HOW WE COULD
ACHIEVE THAT THAT HAD SOM
LEGITIMACY- SO WE REALLY WORKED
HARD ON A ON A POLICY LEVEL. I
HAD TO HAVE THE METRO BOARD FOR
LOS ANGELES YOU ARE THE LESS
INTEREST REGION OF THE COUNTY
IT'S GREATER THAN THAT- TO
BASICALLY DEVELOP A PLAN. THAT
WOULD PROVIDE A BLUEPRINT FOR
HOW YOU COULD PROVIDE A BETTER
ACCESS TO OPEN SPACE AND I'M
PROUD TO SAY THAT. UP MAJOR FOR
ALL THE COMMUNITY NATURE
CONNECTION ANOTHER ALL LONG
TIME ORGANIZATION HERE IN THE
LA AREA THAT HAS PROVIDED
ACCESS TO- TO PARKS. WORKED ON
THIS PLAN AND THAT CREATED
BASICALLY THE FRAMEWORK FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO PURSUE THIS WORK
AND I WANT TO SAY THAT I'M I'M
GOING INTO THIS NOT SO MUCH TO
TELL YOU KNOW WHAT NEUTRAL HAS
DONE. BUT TO DEMONSTRATE HOW
THESE THINGS CAN BE APPLE A
COUPLE ACROSS THE STATE. I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER THAT- YOU DON'T
NEED TO REINVENT THE WHEEL THAT
THERE ARE ALL WE CAN ALL
LEVERAGE EACH OTHER BY SHARING
THIS KIND OF INFORMATION AND
WORKING COLLECTIVELY. HOW TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN AND NOT TO SAY
THAT SOME OF OUR PROGRAMS. ARE
THE BEST FIT FOR EVERY
COMMUNITY. BUT THEY CAN CAN
HELP AND BITING THE BULLET. FOR
THAT. US WHAT WE ARE HAVE TO BE.
MORE TO JUST. OUR PROGRAM BASED
ON ON WHAT WAS. IDENTIFIED IN
THE METRO TRANSIT DEPARTS
STRATEGIC PLAN. IS THAT WE
REALLY WANTED TO FOCUS ON TWO
PROGRAMS ONE BEING COMMUNITY
ACCESS. AND THE SECOND BEING A
SINGAPORE MOUNTAINS- ACCESS
PROGRAM. IN A MINUTE TALK FIRST
ABOUT THE COMMUNITY TRANSIT
PROGRAM BECAUSE I THINK THIS
ONE IS SO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
AS WE'VE SEEN. A RECENTLY OUT
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE AND THIS
PART NEEDS ASSESSMENT- THAT
DELHI COUNTY PARKS DID IS SO
IMPORTANT TO BASICALLY. FRAME
OUR WORK- TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE WORKING IN THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY- I HATE
THAT TERM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHILE INCOME
COMMUNITIES- THAT HAVE NOT HAD.
THE TYPE OF INVESTMENT- THAT
BROTHERS HAVE HAD OVER THE
DECADES. ANDO WE FOCUSED OUR
EFFORTS ON THOSE THREE REGIONS
OF THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY SAN.
GABRIEL VALLEY BIG SHOUT OUT TO.
HOW ARE SIMPLY. NOW BLACK GUY
WHO. DREW BEALE WHO. I
DEFINITELY AT APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENCE ON THIS COMMITTEE AND
THEN IN THE- SOUTHEAST AND LA
AREA WHERE WE HAVE YOU KNOW
SOME REALLY SERIOUS I'LL PARK
ADMISSION SEATS. SO THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE FOCUSING OUR
ATTENTION IN TERMS OF HOW DO WE
GET THOSE PEOPLE OUGHT TO THAT
DARK GREEN AREA THAT YOU SEE AT
THE TOP OF THE MAP WHICH IS OUR
NATIONAL FORESTS. AND THEN ON
THE ON THE LEFT SIDE OF THAT-
THAT GRAPHIC WELL THE SANTA
MONICA MOUNTAINS WHICH ARE ALSO
YOU KNOW THEORETICALLY WITHIN
ABOUT AN HOUR'S DRIVE. FROM
MANY OF THESE COMMUNITIES BUT-
IN REALITY A WORLD AWAY BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THE CHALLENGES OF
TRANSPORTATION ALL COMMUNITY
TRANSIT PROGRAM THAT IS BASED
ON HOGE'S. LOCATED WITHIN THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT COULD PAY TAKE
PEOPLE DIRECTLY ON A REGULAR
BASIS AUG TWO PUBLIC LANDS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND THAT'S WHY
WE THINK THIS PROGRAM. IS JUST-
SO VIABLE- ALL WE KNOW IS THAT-
YOU KNOW THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THE STATE IS
OFFERING AND THAT WE HAVE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. I DO TRY TO
PROMOTE THESE PROJECTS ARE
IMPORTANT- THAT WE FOCUS ON
THOSE COMMUNITIES WITH LIMITED
OPTIONS. THAT WE DELIVER
COMPREHENSIVE WRAP AROUND
SERVICES AND THAT FRANKLY WAS
STATE FUNDING IS I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE DOES VERY WELL HAS
BEEN CHALLENGING BECAUSE OF YOU
KNOW STATE FUNDS SO FAR.
BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
FINDINGS OF DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE LIMITED TO.
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND WE
REALLY NEED TO HAVE THAT
ELEMENT OF COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
BOTH IN THE COMMUNITY AND THEN
AT THE DESTINATIONS TO ENSURE
THAT WERE. EFFECTIVELY YOU'RE
JUST CREATING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH COMMUNITY INSTEAD OF JUST
FRANKLY PROVIDED A BUS SERVICE-
AND WE ALSO WANT TO IN THIS
PROGRAM ALL OFFER SOMETHING
WITH MULTIPLE DESTINATIONS
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WE SHOULDN'T
HAVE ALLOWED JUST ONE OPTION
FOR COMMUNITIES SO THEY SHOULD
BE ABLE TO. GO TO THE BEACHES
IN THE SUMMER GOING TO THE
MOUNTAINS IN THE FALL YOU KNOW
VISIT THEIR LOCAL PARKS WHEN
IT'S COLD BUT MAYBE. YOU KNOW
THEY WANT. TO GET OUTSIDE ALL
THESE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE THERE COULD AND-
APPROACH. SERVICE FROM THE
COMMUNITY. TO THESE. AND HAS AN
ORIENTATION EDUCATIONAL
INTERPRETATION PROGRAMS WHICH
REALLY ALLOWED THE VISITORS TO
UNDERSTAND MORE ABOUT SOME OF
THESE PUBLIC LANDS THAT WE
WOULD BE TAKING THEM TO. AND
I'M JUST GONNA GO THROUGH THESE
REALLY QUICKLY WE HAD A GRANT
FROM KAISER THAT HELPED HELPED
US TO- DO THESE PROJECTS IN
CERTAIN OTHER RIVERS ARE IN
DISTRICTS IN LA COUNTY. ALL YOU
CAN SEE VERY WELL ATTENDED- WE
OPERATE ON A MODEL OF THAT
PROMOTE OTHER ARTISTS IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHICH HELP US TO.
REALLY GENERATE SOME PHENOMENAL
PARTICIPATION. OF THE SECOND
PROGRAM THAT'LL TALK ABOUT VERY
QUICKLY IS CALLED THE SAN
GABRIEL MOUNTAINS- TRANSIT AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM. AND
THIS IS BASICALLY TO TRY TO
MAKE. USE OF THE LIGHT RAIL
SYSTEM IN LA COUNTY OF KNOWN AS
THE GOLD LINE. UP THAT COULD
PROVIDE ACCESS UP INTO THE SAN
GABRIEL MOUNTAINS WE HAVE HAD
SO MANY MANY PILOT PROJECTS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS-
SINCE ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. AFTER THE SANDY
MOUNTAINS NATIONAL MONUMENT WAS
PROCLAIMED BY PRESIDENT OBAMA.
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF INTEREST
ON HOW WE CAN GET PEOPLE UP
INTO THE MOUNTAINS AND I THINK
THAT THE OTHER POINT I WANNA
MAKE REAL QUICKLY ABOUT BOTH
THESE PROGRAMS BOTH THE GOLD
LINE PROGRAM AND UP. IN THE
COMMUNITY TRANSIT PROGRAM SOME
OF THE COROLLARY BENEFITS ARE
ABOUT. REDUCING B. M. T. MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE PROTECTING OUR
RESOURCES BY NOT HAVING SO MANY
PEOPLE USE OUR ROADS. AND HAVE
IMPACTS TO THOSE YOU KNOW.
RELATIVELY LIMITED ACCESS
POINTS THAT WE HAVE BEEN TO
SOME OF THESE PUBLIC LANDS. SO
IT'S REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
PROJECT AND THIS IS NOT A NEW
IDEA. THROUGH THE SLIDE IN
THERE BECAUSE IT REALLY
DEMONSTRATES THE FACT THAT- YOU
KNOW THESE KINDS OF ACCESS
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN AROUND. FOR
A VERY LONG TIME THIS IS THAT
YOU KNOW THE NUCLEAR THAT WAS
VERY ACTIVE- BACK IN THE DAY
AND IT MIGHT FORGET THE EXACT
DATE BUT- THEY YEAR IT'S BEEN
AN OPERABLE FOR DECADES- BUT
PROVIDES US. WITH A WINDOW INTO
YOU KNOW WHAT SOME OF THESE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE. AND- YOU
KNOW SAYS TO REALLY SEE KNOW
HOW WE DEMONSTRATE THIS FOR THE
FOR. AWESOME YOU KNOW WHY ARE
WE DOING THIS AND BURNELL
JUSTICE YOU KNOW 82% OF OUR
COMMUNITIES OUR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. THEY HAVE POOR PUBLIC
HEALTH THEY HAVE NATURE DEFICIT
DISORDER ALL RIGHT AND- IN
ORDER- YOU KNOW ENGAGEMENT WITH
THE PUBLIC. IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
LACK OF TRANSPORTATION IS BOTH
THE NUMBER ONE AND THE NUMBER
TWO BARRIER- TO ACCESS TO THE
OUTDOORS. ON YOU KNOW THE ISSUE
OF HOW WE CAN MAKE THIS PROGRAM
OPERATIONAL AND HOW CAN BE A
GAME CHANGER. IS YOU KNOW A
PRETTY SELF EVIDENT. IT SAYS
70% OF LA COUNTY'S OPEN SPACE
IS THE SAME PEOPLE MOUNTAINS
PART OF THE U. S. FOREST
SERVICE ONE IN TWENTY AMERICANS
SEVENTEEN MILLION PEOPLE EVERY
TIME I SAY THAT. IS BE THE
CHILLS LIVE WITHIN A NINETY
MINUTE DRIVE OF THE COOSA
RESOURCE. AND THESE MOUNTAINS
OF PROVIDED YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
RECREATIONAL ACCESS IN THE
STATE IT SURPASSES EVEN YOU
SOMEBODY. ALL RIGHT AND OF
COURSE YOU KNOW I'VE TALKED
ABOUT THE MULTIPLE BENEFITS
ALREADY. ALL THESE LINES ON
THIS MAP- ARE ABOUT THE LIGHT
RAIL SYSTEMS IN LA COUNTY AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WANT
TO. POINT OUT- I'M SORRY FOR IT
APPARENTLY DID NOT BRING THE
SITE WITH ME. BUT THE GOLD LINE
IN PARTICULAR THAT I DESCRIBED
EARLIER WITH THAT PROVIDES THE
ACCESS DIRECTLY INTO THE SAINT
GABRIEL'S. GOES THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY OF EAST LA. IN LOS
ANGELES WHICH IS ONE OF THE
MOST TRANSIT DEPENDENT
COMMUNITIES THAT WE HAVE IN THE
COUNTY. AND THIS WILL PROVIDE
THEM WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO- TO
ACCESS. THE SAME GIVE OR
MOUNTAINS. SO YOU KNOW WHY THIS
IS THE- TIME WITH HER MANY OF
THINGS ARE READY- IN. OF THE
YOUR SPEECH. AT A TERM DEMAND
FOR THE OUTDOORS IN PARTICULAR
NOW WE CALLED IT. THERE'S A
STARK DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO
NATURE ALL WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
POLITICAL WILL AND FUNDING
ALIGNMENT IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT THESE PROGRAMS.
AND ALL THERE WAS A DOT DESIRE
FROM AN EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS.
ALL WE'VE HAD TONS OF PILOT
PROJECTS AND MANY YOU KNOW
GREAT PHOTOS TO. TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT. ON AT THE END OF THE DAY-
MY EASY SENTIMENT AND WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO CONVEY TO ALL OF
YOU IS THAT. YOU KNOW LET'S GET
DONE WITH THE PILOT PROJECTS WE
NEED TO MAE THIS WORK-
AFFECTED COMMUNITY LED
EQUITABLE ACCESS PROGRAMS ARE
CRITICALLY NEEDED. ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE NOW WOULD
THERE SAY THROUGHOUT THE NATION
YOU KNOW THIS IS JUST. A WAY
THAT WE HAVE TO CONNECT OUR
PEOPLE TO DO THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO MAKE THEM HEALTHIER-
INTO IT BOTH. PHYSICAL HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH. ALL WE HAVE
TO HAVE ADAPTABLE POLICIES
WHICH YOU KNOW I. REALLY
COMMEND STATE PARKS FOR ALL
WHAT THEY'VE DONE WITH THE
OUTDOOR EQUITY PROGRAM IN
MAKING SURE THAT IT IS GOING TO
MEET OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS. WE
NEED FUNDING AT THE FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL- AND
HOPEFULLY YOU KNOW SOME OF THA
FEDERAL FUNDING IS GOING TO
COME TO US- YOU KNOW SOON- WE
WANT TO IDENTIFY WHAT ARE THE
SUCCESS STORIES THAT ALREADY
EXIST. AND ELEVATE THOSE
PROGRAMS SO THAT THEY CAN- THEY
CAN BE FUNDED. SO I HOPE THAT
WAS QUICK ENOUGH AND I TOOK A
LITTLE BIT OF. EXTRA TIME BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. DISCUSS THESE
THINGS WITH YOU AND I JUST WANT
TO DO A BIG SHOUT OUT TO A
PARTY OUT. OF AN ORGANIZATION
THAT I'VE HAD A STRONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH WITH NOW FOR.
MANY YEARS AND THEY HAVE A
MEMBERSHIP FROM THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND I THINK- WOULD BE
REALLY. INTERESTED IN
COLLABORATING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE IN ORDER TO FURTHER
THE EFFORTS SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU BELINDA YOU
ANSWERED A COUPLE QUESTIONS WE
HAD AS A RELATED TO EQUITABLE
ACCESS BARRIERS ENCOUNTERING.
PEOPLE. FOR OUTDOOR IT. AND
ALSO- YOU GIVE US A GOOD. OF
SOME OF THE WORK THAT YOU'RE-
IT NATURE FOR. THING YOU THERE
ARE ANY OTHER. WILL GET AT THE
TOP. I'M GONNA ASK MARK.
HINDLEY IF HE CAN YOU KNOW
CONDENSES PLANTATION TIPPING UP
THREE MINUTES AS WELL AS- HELP
WITH WALLS LAWLER. AND AND THEN
WE CAN TRY TO GET. SOME SPEED
QUESTIONS AT THE END WE'RE
WE'RE DOWN TO ABOUT TEN MINUTES
SO- THANK YOU. FLOOR'S YOURS
NOW FOR NEXT WEEK- MISTER MARK
KELLY YEP CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
SIR. IT WAS BUSTED RIGHT. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK KELLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS AND PUBLIC POLICY. AND
WE REPRESENT ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND- MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE. ABU OUR STAFF WORKS
WITH- THEM TO CONSERVE WATER
FOWL HABITAT AT WETLANDS AND
PROTECT OUR HUNTING HERITAGE SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ALL ABOUT- I
WILL TRY TO CUT MY PRESENTATION
DOWN- HERE A LITTLE BIT WHEN I
JUMPED WITH GLEE INTO WHAT I
THINK CAN BE DONE TO HELP
INCREASE- HUH- SPECIFICALLY
HUNTING ACCESS- AND ENCOURAGE
MORE PARTICIPATION IN
CALIFORNIA- SPECIFICALLY ON-
DEAR DEPARTMENT FISH WILDLIFE
PLANTS. FOR ME IT NEEDS MORE
FUNDING AND STAFF TO MANAGE IT
STATE WILDLIFE AREAS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHICH
INCLUDE MANAGE WETLANDS BECAUSE
THOSE MANAGED WETLANDS COSTS
SIGNIFICANT SUMS OF MONEY TO
MAINTAIN ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
EXPENSES RELATED UP PUMPING
WATER MISKITO ABATE MET FUEL
NOXIOUS WEED CONTROL HAVE ALL
RISEN SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS BUT THE BUDGETS
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE NOT KEPT
PACE WITH THAT- WILDLIFE
HABITAT QUALITY NOT ONLY
STOPPERS BUT IT CAN ALSO REDUCE
TO NEGATIVELY IMPACT
RECREATIONAL USE ONE FOR
EXAMPLE. WETLAND FLOODING HAS
TO BE DELAYED BECAUSE THERE'S
INSUFFICIENT FUNDS TO PUMP
WATER. OUT WHILE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OUR WORK
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE
LANDS AND THEIR MANAGEMENT I
THINK A LOT MORE RESOURCES NEED
TO BE TAKE DEDICATED THERE
WE'VE GOT A LONG CALL TO GO TO
REALLY GET THOSE. WILDLIFE
AREAS OPERATING AT THEIR
OPTIMAL CAPACITY. SOMETHING
ELSE OUT WE THINK NEEDS TO BE
LOOKED AT- WE HAVE A VERY
ANTIQUATED LICENSE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA HUNTING LICENSE
SYSTEM AND FISHING LICENSE-
THAT NEEDS TO BE FULLY
INTEGRATED INTO AN ELECTRONIC
SYSTEM. WHILE OTHER STATES HAVE
EMBRACED TECHNOLOGY CALIFORNIA
FOR EXAMPLE STILL RELIES ON
PAPER HUNTING AND FISHING
LICENSES. THIS NOT NOT ONLY
MAKES IT MORE BURDENSOME ON THE
HUNDRED CHOIR AND PROVED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE FIELD THAT
HERE SHE HAS ALL THE REQUIRED
LICENSES AND VALIDATIONS BUT
IT'S FRANKLY A DISINCENTIVE FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE BETTER
VERSED IN TECHNOLOGY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE HUNTING. SO
ALLOWING LICENSES AND
VALIDATIONS TO BE DISPLAYED ON
A MOBILE DEVICE WOULD PROVIDE
CONVENIENCE AND ALSO FULLY
BRING OUR LICENSING SYSTEM INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
THERE'S A WONDERFUL PROGRAM
THAT THAT HAS BEEN ON THE BOOKS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THREE CALLED
THE SHARE PROGRAM. AND WE WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO SEE THAT PROGRAM
EXPANDED. SHARE PROGRAM- IS
THERE A PROGRAM WHERE THE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE
PROVIDES FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
TO LANDOWNERS- TO BASICALLY
ALLOW ACCESS FOR HUNTING AND
OTHER WILDLIFE DEPENDENT
RECREATION. IN DOING SO THE
PROGRAM ALSO ENCOURAGES
LANDOWNERS TO MAINTAIN OUR LAND
AS WILDLIFE HABITAT SO IT HAS
THE DUAL BENEFIT. THE PROBLEM
HAS BEEN THE FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM IT'S BEEN VERY LIMITED-
IT'S BEEN MOSTLY GENERATED BY
USER FEES- IMPOSED ON THE
RECREATIONAL PARTICIPANTS IN
THE PROGRAM. WHICH IS REALLY
RESTRICTED THE NUMBER OF
PROPERTIES THAT THE DEPARTMENT
CAN AND ROLL UP AND DOWN THE
STATE. SO WE WOULD SAY THAT
FUTURE YOU KNOW PARKING OPEN
SPACE BOND SHOULD. BE AMENDED
TO INCLUDE FUNDING SPECIFICALLY
FOR THIS PROGRAM IT'S A IT'S A
WONDERFUL PROGRAM WE KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF DEMAND FOR IT
AND WE JUST NEED FUNDING TO ARE
REALLY FULLY IMPLEMENTED AND
TAKE IT STATEWIDE. WE ALSO
WOULD RECOMMEND- THE STATE
CREATED OR STRENGTHENED
PARTNERSHIPS WITH NON- WITHOUT
CONSERVATION ON PROFITS A
GROWING NUMBER OF NONPROFIT
CONSERVATION GROUPS IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO GET MORE
PEOPLE INTO THE OUTDOORS OUR
ORGANIZATION HAS DEVELOPED A
HUNT PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
HIGH QUALITY PUBLIC ACCESS FOR
WATERFOWL HUNTING TO SIXTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF PRIVATE LAND
INCLUDING SEVERAL PROPERTIES-
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN THE
SYSTEM IN MARCH. THAT WE
ACTUALLY OWNED IN FEE- THIS
MOST NOTABLY INCLUDES- SPECIAL
HONEY OPPORTUNITIES FOR ACTIVE
DUTY MIDDLE MILITARY PERSONNEL
AND VETERANS. SO THAT'S A GREAT
PART OF OUR PROGRAM IN OUR VIEW.
ALTHOUGH IT WAS CURTAILED LAST
YEAR BECAUSE THE CODE WE ALSO
OFFER YOUTH AND EDUCATION CAMPS
DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY TO
INTRODUCE NEWCOMERS TO HUNTING
FISHING AND THE OUTDOORS- IN
ADDITION WE ADMINISTER. THE
BECOMING AN OUTDOORS WOMAN
PROGRAM. WHICH MANY OF YOU HAVE
PROBABLY. FOCUSES ON PROVIDING
WOMEN WHO TEND TO BE
UNDERREPRESENTED IN THE HUNTING
AND FISHING COMMUNITY WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN OUTDOOR
SKILLS- IN A SAFE AND-
ENCOURAGING ENVIRONMENT- WE'RE
ALSO WORKING BY THE WAY WITH-
ON FUTURE INITIATIVES WITH
OUTDOOR AFRICA EXCUSE ME
OUTDOOR AFRO. WHICH FOCUSES ON
CONNECTING AFRICAN AMERICANS
WITHOUT DOOR EXPERIENCES SO
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
THE PROGRAMS- THAT I JUST
TALKED ABOUT RELY HEAVILY ON
VOLUNTEERS AND DONATIONS TO
KEEP COSTS TO THE PUBLIC AT A
MINIMUM- THAT DEMAND FOR THESE
PROGRAMS TYPICALLY EXCEEDS
AVAILABLE SPACE. AND SOME
PEOPLE MUST UNFORTUNATELY BE
TURNED AWAY. THE MAJOR LIMITING
FACTOR THOUGH IS THE AMOUNT OF
AVAILABLE LANDS AND VENUES. IF
THE STATE COULD OFFER UP SOME
OF ITS OWN PROPERTIES WHERE NON
PROFITS COULD IMPLEMENT THEIR
OUTDOOR ACCESS PROGRAMS. THAT
WOULD CERTAINLY ALLOW MORE
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE SO I
THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
THERE. I ALSO KNOW THAT- THERE
ARE SOME STATE PROPERTIES WITH
THE STATES SIMPLY DOESN'T HAVE
THE STAFF RESOURCES TO
ADMINISTER PUBLIC USE PROGRAMS.
IN THESE CASES NONPROFIT
CONSERVATION CONSERVATION
GROUPS COULD HELP TO FILL THAT
VOID MAKE THEM YOU KNOW USABLE
FOR THE PUBLIC. SO THEY'RE
REAL- ARE THESE OPPORTUNITIES
OUT ON THE TABLE AND WE JUST
NEED TO I THINK FULLY COME
TOGETHER AND- FIVE DAY OUT
WORKING AGREEMENT AND IMPLEMENT
THEM AND DOUBT THAT WOULD
CERTAINLY HELP TO SOLVE SOME OF
THIS PROBLEM THAT WERE SEEN OUT
ON THE LANDSCAPE. SO WITH THAT-
I AM OPEN TO ANY QUESTIONS OR
ANY INFORMATION THAT YOU MAY
NEED THANK YOU THANK YOU MARK
THAT WAS GREAT- APPRECIATE YOU.
JUMPING RIGHT IN IN TERMS OF
WHAT SOME OF THE ISSUES ARE
THAT- THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE
SOME SUGGESTIONS OR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON SELF WE'RE
GONNA GO INTO A- KELLY WALSH
LAWLER THE PRESIDENT OF C. AND
C. O. PARKS CALIFORNIA WE'RE
DOWN TO THE LAST FIVE MINUTES.
GOING TO SEE IF WE CAN. GET
THIS PRESENTATION DONE AND THEN
GET SOME SPEED QUESTIONS AND AT
THE END SO. THANK YOU FOR YOURS.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR COMMITTEE FOR INVITING ME
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS KELLY I'M
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF PARKS
CALIFORNIA. AS CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS STATUTORY PARTNER WE HAVE
A SIMPLE MISSION IS TO HELP
STRENGTHEN PARKS INSPIRE ALL TO
EXPERIENCE THESE EXTRAORDINARY
PLACES. AS BACKGROUND QUICKLY
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE PARKS FOR
COMMISSION WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED AT THE DIRECTION OF
THE GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE
DECIDED ADOPTED THE PARKS
FORWARD PLAN. A PARK SUPPORT
ENTITY NOW KNOWN AS PARKS
CALIFORNIA WAS A PART OF THAT
PLAN. AND IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
SENATE PASSED SB ELEVEN ELEVEN
WHICH AUTHORIZED THE DEPARTMENT
TO ENTER INTO A RELATIONSHIP.
FIRST CALIFORNIA WAS
ESTABLISHED IN DECEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND IS A FIVE OH ONE
SEE THREE PARTNER WORKING FROM
THE INSIDE OUT. WITH CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS. WE HAVE AN MO YOU
WITH THE DEPARTMENT THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON SEVEN KEY GOALS
WHICH I'LL TOUCH UPON THE
ACTUAL WORK THAT WE DO TOGETHER.
ANNUALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS CALIFORNIA NOW USED A
FORMALIZED PROCESS JUST LIKE
SELECT SHARED PRIORITY
INITIATIVES AND PROJECTS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION WE KNOW OUR
STRENGTH IS IN OUR
COLLABORATION. WE'VE HEARD THAT
NUMEROUS TIMES THROUGHOUT THE
MORNING. OUR WORK HAS THREE
AREAS OF FOCUS AGAIN LANDED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND REC. THE FIRST IS
ACCESS INTERPRETATION AND
EDUCATION. THE SECOND NATURAL
RESOURCES PROTECTION AND
STEWARDSHIP AND THE THIRD PARTY
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS. ON AXIS
INTERPRETATION AND EDUCATION
WE'RE HELPING TO CLOSE THE PARK
ACCESS GAP. CALIFORNIA WORKS
THE DEPARTMENT TO ADDRESS
BARRIERS TO KEEP MANY FROM
EXPLORING AND APPRECIATING
STATE PARKS AND PUBLIC LANDS.
AND OUR UNIQUE APPROACH WHICH
IS PUSHES BEYOND VISITATION
GOALS TO ALSO ADDRESS VISITOR
EXPERIENCE AND RELEVANCY.
FOSTERING DEEPER RELATIONSHIPS
WITH NATURE AND ULTIMATELY A
NEW GENERATION THAT LOVES AND
SUPPORTS CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS. ARE WORKING PROGRAMMATIC
APPROACH IS CENTERED ON
INVESTING IN TRANSPORTATION
SOLUTIONS FOR ACCESS. IMPROVING
OUTDOOR ACCESS AND PARKOUR
COMMUNITIES FOR EXAMPLE THROUGH
A ROUTINE PART SMART PROGRAM.
ELEVATING THE VISIBILITY OF
PARKS YOUR STORYTELLING AND
COMMUNICATIONS INCLUDING AN
EMPHASIS ON THE SUCCESS OF THE
PROP. SIXTY EIGHT FUNDED
STATEWIDE PARK PROGRAM. TELL
MORE OF THE UNTOLD THAT
OCCURRED ON THESE PROTECTED
LANDS AND ALSO RUN THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT OF PARK
CONNECTION PROGRAMS THAT
INCLUDE JUNIOR RANGERS JUNIOR
LIFEGUARDS AND PORTS. SO
INTEGRAL TO TEACHERS STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES AND TWENTY TWENTY
REACHING OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS DURING CO. UNDER
NATURAL RESOURCES PROTECTION
AND STEWARDSHIP WE WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF NATURAL RESOURCES
DIVISION. WE WORK TO STRENGTHEN
LANDSCAPE SCALE STEWARDSHIP TO
ADDRESS PRESSING CHALLENGES OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. TO ENSURE THE PARKS
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE
BIODIVERSITY FOR GENERATIONS.
WE KNOW STATE PARKS CANNOT
TACKLE CLIMATE CHANGE ALONE
WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER TO
DEVELOP A PORTFOLIO OF
PARTNERSHIPS. INNOVATIVE TOOLS
TRAININGS AND WORKFORCES ALLMAN
OPPORTUNITIES. TO MEET THESE
PRESSING CHALLENGES WE KNOW WE
NEED MORE TRAINED STEWARDS AT
ALL PROFESSIONAL LEVELS ACROSS
THE STATE TO IMPLEMENT CLIMATE
RESILIENT SOLUTIONS. WE ALSO
RECENTLY LAUNCHED HER CAREER
PATHWAYS GRANT PROGRAM TO GROW
AND STRENGTHEN THE WORK FORCE
BY HELPING TO ENSURE THAT STATE
PARKS WORKFORCE REFLECTS THE
RICH DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
GROWING POPULATION. LASTLY
PARKS CALIFORNIA FOCUSES ON
PARK CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS BY
WORKING TO AUGMENT THE FUND
RAISING CAPACITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT OF
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. AS WE ALL
WORK COLLECTIVELY TO ENGAGE THE
NEXT GENERATION OF PARK
VISITORS MUST ALSO CONSIDER
WHAT THE FUTURE PARK VISIT WILL
ENTAIL. WE KNOW OUR LEGACY MUST
PROVIDE A WORLD CLASS
EXPERIENCE AND VIBRANT HEALTHY
PARKS THAT WELCOME ENGAGE AND
INSPIRE. BY WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND PARTNERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WILL HELP
STRENGTHEN OUR STATE PARK
SYSTEM. TO ENSURE THAT OUR
PARKS AND OUR COMMUNITIES BOTH
THRIVE EVERYONE HAS A ROLE TO
PLAY IN CREATING THIS LEGACY
AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO BE
HERE. TO BE A PART OF IT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
WHERE WE HIT THE TWELVE MARK WE
DON'T HAVE ANYBODY ON. PUBLIC
COMMENTS. AT THIS POINT- BUT-
BELINDA DID TOUCH ON A LOT OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT WE HAD
OUTLINED FOR A MARK. WE DO HAVE
A QUESTION AS IT RELATES TO
METRICS THAT SHOW ATTENDANCE IN
THE ORGANIZATION'S PROGRAMS.
AND WE ARE THE KIND OF EXPANDED
INTERESTS. AND ATTRACTING
DIVERSE POPULATIONS OF THE
STATE AND THEN FOR- PARKS
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW BUT THIS
MODEL IS UNIQUE- THAT WE WANT
TO KIND OF CONTINUE TO
HIGHLIGHT. THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING TO SUPPORT- THE STATE
AGENCY AND OTHER ENTITIES DOING
THIS WORK. WHAT WE'D LIKE TO
HEAR YOU KNOW WHAT- WHAT OTHER
AREAS OF SUPPORT DO YOU THINK
THAT THE ORGANIZATION CAN
PROVIDE- THE STATE AGENCY TO
REACH ACHIEVE ITS GOALS OF
ACCESS TO PARKS. SO WHAT WILL
GO TO MARK IN THE END OF A
DOLLAR AND I THINK AFTER THAT-
IF THERE AREN'T ANY-
INDIVIDUALS ON THE CALL- WE
WILL HAVE- COMPLETED OUR OUR
HEARING BUT. THE MARKET STILL
WITH US THE. CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY GREAT YEAH
IN TERMS OF METRICS WE DO
SURVEYS OF PARTNERS IN WHICH WE
LOOK AT THE DEMOGRAPHICS AND
SEE HOW WE ARE CHANGING OVER
TIME AND I WILL SAY WITHIN THE
LAST FIVE TO TEN YEARS WE
HAVEN'T. GOTTEN A GREATER
NUMBER OF WOMEN TO PARTICIPATE-
IN HONEY WE'VE ALSO SEEN TRUE
THAT BECOMING ABOUT OUTDOORS
WOMAN PROGRAM. GREAT INTEREST
IN OUR HUNTING AND FISHING AND
AGAIN THE AVAILABLE SPACE- IT
HAS BEEN EXCEEDED BY THE DEMAND
SO WE KNOW THERE THERE ARE
QUITE A FEW WOMEN THAT DO YOU
WANT TO GET. INTO THE OUTDOORS
AND EXPERIENCE HUNTING AND
FISHING. I THINK- THERE
PROBABLY IS ROOM TO DO A MORE
SCIENTIFIC SURVEY THOUGH OF
WHAT'S GOING ON IN CALIFORNIA.
SO I WOULD CERTAINLY YES
SUPPORT SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW JUST SURVEY
INFORMATION AND ANECDOTAL
INFORMATION ISN'T GOING TO CUT
IT WE NEED TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE
MORE OF A SCIENTIFIC- ANGLE ON
ALL THIS SO THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE WE
SHOULD LOOK TO IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU MARK. THE NEXT
QUESTION NOT TOO MUCH OLDER-
JUST KIND OF HIGHLIGHTING SOME
THE STATE AGENCY AND THEN ALSO
LOOKING AT THIS MODEL- THE- ARE
WE SEEING THIS SAME APPROACH IN
OTHER PLACES. AROUND THE
COUNTRY. YES THANK YOU I THINK
IT'S A COMBINATION OF THINGS
THAT WILL HELP US MOVE THIS
PARTNERSHIP FORWARD ONE I THINK
THAT WE NEED- TO CONTINUE DOING
THESE FORMALIZED SHARE PRIORITY
SETTING MOMENTS IN TIME WHERE
WE DO CALL TO ACTION ACROSS ALL
PARK DISTRICTS SO WE'RE HEARING
FROM THE PARKS. EMPLOYEES ON
THE GROUND AND ALSO WITH THE
SACRAMENTAL LEVEL WE'RE
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE ISSUES
ARE ON BOTH AT THE DISTRICT
LEVEL BUT ALSO AT THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL. ARE GRANT PROGRAMS ARE
DEEPLY EMBEDDED INTO COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT SO THAT WE ARE
HEARING AGAIN FROM COMMUNITIES
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES THOSE
WHO ARE STRUGGLING MOST WITH
ACCESS AND RELEVANCY WHEN THEY
DO ARRIVE INTO PARKS ON WHAT
THEY NEED AND HOW WE CAN BEST
SERVE THEM. AND THE THIRD
COMPONENT IS FUNDRAISING WE ARE
HERE TO ADD FUNDING INTO THE
SYSTEM- THROUGH- THROUGH
PRIVATE SECTOR FOUNDATIONS AND
INDIVIDUALS WE'RE HERE TO HELP
WITH ALL OF THOSE DIFFERENT
AREAS AND FEEL- THAT IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS AND- AS THEY LOOK
FORWARD I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
STATUTORY PARTNERS ARE ARE
TYPICAL AS WE LOOK NATIONWIDE.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THIS WAS
BORN THROUGH SB ELEVEN ELEVEN
THAT THIS WAS MEANT TO SERVE AS-A MODEL ON TO BE ANALYZED AS A
MODEL AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
POTENTIAL- NATIONAL GROWTH
MODELS OF BUT RIGHT NOW I
BELIEVE WE ARE. WE ARE PAVING
THE WAY. ONE MORE QUESTION IS
THERE A SPECIFIC- PROJECT A
PROGRAM THAT YOU'RE WORKING
WITH STATE PARKS TO REALLY-
CELEBRATE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
HIGHLIGHTS- SOME POSITIVE
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING. THEN
I'VE GOT A QUESTION FOR BELINDA
THEY JUST CAME IN FROM- FOLKS
WATCHING- EFFORTS TO DEVELOP
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERS- SO WILL
WILL THEN WITH THOSE TWO
QUESTIONS. YOU KNOW I'M I'M
EXCITED ABOUT ONE PARTICULAR
MULTI STAKEHOLDER PARTNERSHIP
THAT WE HAVE JUST KICKED OFF
OFFICIALLY IN SOUTH FRESNO
CALLED OUTDOOR ACCESS TOGETHER
AND GRANT TO COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES. AND LEVERAGING
MULTIPLE NONPROFIT PARTNERS
INCLUDING LATINO OUTDOORS AND
OUTDOORS AND POWER NETWORK AND
THIS PROGRAM IS FOCUSED WITH
THE COMMUNITY WHO'S ASKED FOR
THAT ACCESS WHO WANT MORE
COMFORT AND RELEVANCE WHEN THEY
GO TO PARKS. AND WE'RE WORKING
AS A CONNECTOR- BRINGING IN
FUNDING TO THE MULTI
STAKEHOLDER APPROACH BUT ALSO
HELPING TO BRING THE COMMUNITY
OUT TO MILLER TEN WHICH IS ONE
OF THE CLOSEST STATE PARKS. AND
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH STATE PARK
EMPLOYEES ON THE GROUND IN THAT
PARK. WHO ARE READY FOR THEM
WHEN THEY ARRIVE AND WHOARE
THERE TO SUPPORT AND HELP THEM.
I THINK AS WE LOOK MORE BROADLY
AT LISTENING TO COMMUNITY NEEDS
AND HELPING TO PLAY THAT
CONNECTOR ROLE WHICH DOES
INCLUDE A COMPONENT OF FUNDING
WE SEE A REAL SCALABLE
INNOVATIVE OPPORTUNITY MOVING
FORWARD STATEWIDE. GREAT THANK
YOU. A BLENDER SURE IT WILL
JUST CHIME IN REAL QUICKLY I
EAT- MENTIONED EARLIER HAVE
BEEN IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORLD
FOR PROBABLY ABOUT THIRTY YEARS
AND IT'S BEEN REALLY. EYE
OPENING IN THE LAST TEN YEARS
AND HOW DIVERSITY IN DURHAM BUT
IN MINT HAS BECOME AND THAT IS
BECAUSE OF EMERGING LEADERS
SADDAM NORMA IS A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF THAT- AND THEN- THROUGH
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
THAT I KNOW MANY ORGANIZATIONS
RUN STATEWIDE WELL WE'RE SEEING
A CHANGING DYNAMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP AWARD
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO THAT IT
IS MORE DIVERSE- BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO FOCUS
ON I THINK WE STILL HAVE A LONG
WAY TO GO- WHEN IT COMES TO YOU
KNOW GOVERNMENT. APPLICATIONS
OF- DEVELOPING A NEW LEADERS
AND MANAGERS AND DIRECTORS OF
ORGANIZATIONS I WAS SO GLAD TO
SEE ME- MISTER KING DENTAL-
SELECTED AS A STATE PARK
DIRECTOR WELL WE NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB- AND I THINK THAT
IT'S CLOSE ACROSS THE BOARD-
ERROR ASIAN YOU KNOW WHAT. THE
PHILLY IT'S AND BLACK-
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ALSO NEED TO
BE AS VISIBLE SO WE JUST NEED
TO KEEP WORKING AT IT AND MAKE
SURE THAT- WE'RE ADVOCATING FOR
BETTER CALLS TO PROGRAMS TO
FACILITATE THE WHOLE PROCESS%
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND THAT IS
A QUESTION THAT- YOU KNOW WE
RAISE- THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AGENCIES SPECIFICALLY THIS
WASTED WERE TALKING ABOUT AND
SO. TRULY APPRECIATE YOUR
HONEST RESPONSE TO THAT I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING WE DID GO BACK
OVER BUT THEY'RE WELL WORTH THE
TIME AND THE INFORMATION THAT'S
BEEN PROVIDED I ALSO WANT TO
JUST ACKNOWLEDGE A- THE PRIOR-
PANELISTS THAT WERE WITH US IN
THE PRIOR TO THE SEGMENT'S. AT
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY COLLEAGUES
THAT WERE HERE WE HAD A PRETTY
GOOD TURN OUT FOR THE MAJORITY
OF THE A HEARING A STAY TUNED
FOR ADDITIONAL HEARINGS ON
SUBJECTS RELATED TO WHAT WE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY BUT- MIGHT
MY GRATITUDE TO ALL OF YOU
PARTICIPATE ALSO ARE RECOGNIZED
THE TEAM FROM THE BALL PARKS-
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE FOR HELPING. US PUT
THIS TOGETHER BRINGING ALL OF
YOU ON ON BOARD WITH THAT- I
DON'T KNOW- MINUTE LOOKED SEE
WE DON'T HAVE ANYBODY IN THE
PALM. COMMENT Q. SO WHILE WE
THAT MISTER CHAIR. YEAH NAME IS
YOUR I DO. WE MAY HAVE ONE
PERSON WHO WISHES TO SPEAK.
ALLARDYCE I'M NOT COMPLETELY
SURE. BUT I'LL JUST INVITE THAT
PERSON HAS TO PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO PLEASE. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
LINE TWELVE- PARDON ME JUST A
MOMENT THANK YOU ONE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF- THIS
IS RICO MONSTER DID NOT- WITH
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND. I
FIRST WANT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR YOUR INDISPENSABLE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE HI
LIGHTED BY- MAKING THAT A
PRIORITY EVER SINCE YOU CAME TO
THE LEGISLATURE- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. I WANT TO
FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON OUR QUEST
AFTER AND- EQUITY- THE EVIDENCE
OF THE MULTI BENEFITS OF THE
PARK INDISPUTABLE. WE KNOW-
HUMAN HEALTH BOTH PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL CLIMATE ADAPTATION
RECREATION QUALITY OF LIFE
ENHANCE BIODIVERSITY BETTER
WATER QUALITY AND AIR QUALITY
YOU KNOW ALL OF THESE THINGS WE
KNOW WHAT. THE DOWNSIDE OF NOT
HAVING PARKS THAT CAN CHARGE.
THE POOR HUMAN HELP HIGHER
CHILDHOOD OBESITY LOWER QUALITY
OF LIFE AND IT'S REALLY A
QUESTION OF PRIORITIES AND
VALUES AND THE CHALLENGE. IS
RELIABLE ON GOING FUNDING FOR
THESE PROGRAMS IT'S NOT A
QUESTION OF WHETHER THE
STATEWIDE PARK PROGRAM IS. IT'S
ACCEPTABLE IT'S BEEN OVER
SUBSCRIBED BY A 1000% YOUR BEEN
GREENING- PROGRAM AT NATURAL
RESOURCES IS ALSO
OVERSUBSCRIBED ENOUGH HUNDREDS
OF PERCENT. AND VERY SUCCESSFUL
ACCEPTABLE TO COMMUNITIES YEAH
WE ARE DEPENDENT ON BONDS FOR-
TO FUND THESE PROGRAMS THAT IS
NOT. A APPROACH AT THE LA- THAT
APPROPRIATE SOURCE TO SUPPORT
ON GOING PROGRAMS AND THEY'RE
UNRELIABLE- WE WANTED WE ALL
THOUGHT WE WOULD HAVE A BOND
LAST YEAR AND UP BECAUSE OF
CIRCUMSTANCES OUT OF OUR
CONTROL THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN. WE
HOPE TO HAVE A BOND IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUT WE DON'T KNOW
THAT THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN EITHER
AND EVEN IF IT DOES WE WON'T
HAVE NEW MONEY UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AT THE EARLIEST.
THE LAST FUNDING FOR THE STATE
WIDE PART PROGRAM IS GOING OUT
THE FLOTATION OF- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR MITCHELL MAN CHIMP IS
HAPPENING ON TWELFTH THAT THE
LAB ABOUT MONEY YOU'RE BEING.
PROGRAM DIDN'T EVEN HELP
PROPOSE FUNDING FOR IT THIS
YEAR IN THE- AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO WORK THE LET'S. TO
RESTORE FUNDING THAT PROGRAM SO
IT'S OBVIOUSLY NOT DOESN'T SEEM
TO BE A HOT IT STARKLY A HIGH
PRIORITY BUT LOOKED AT AS AN
AMENITY. SO THE CHALLENGE TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE LEADERS
LIKE YOU. IS TOUGH LOOK FOR-
FUNDING SOURCES ARE MORE
RELIABLE- WE NEED ON GOING
FUNDING THE NEED IS THERE- THE-
YOU KNOW CONSEQUENCE OF NOT
FUNDING- PARK ACCESS. IS
DEVASTATING AND- THE FIRST
PLACE WE SHOULD START THIS TO
MAKE SURE PARTS ARE WITHIN
WALKING DISTANCE OF PEOPLE AND
LOW INCOME DENSELY POPULATED
URBAN AREAS. WE SHOULD BE
PUTTING PARKS WHERE PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE TO RELY ON
TRANSPORTATION OR- SOME OTHER
WAY TO GET TO THE PLATE THE-
AND THEY CAN ACTUALLY WALK LIKE
SOME CALIFORNIANS CAN. SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'VE-
DONE YOUR WHOLE CAREER HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE I APPRECIATE
THE STAFF VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
TODAY I THINK IT'S IMMENSELY
IMPORTANT. BUT IT ALWAYS BOILS
DOWN TO PRIORITIES VALUES AND
FUNDING AND OUR- WE WOULDN'T
HAVE- YOU KNOW HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN STATE
COURT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WORK
OVERSUBSCRIBED PROGRAMS. IN THE
THOUSANDS OF PERCENT IF WE
WERE- PROVIDING ADEQUATE
FUNDING TO BASELINE ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR THESE PROGRAMS SO I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY SO.
TO SPEAK I- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS HEARING AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO- YOU KNOW OFFERING
MY- OPINIONS AND SUGGESTIONS
AND ANY SUBSEQUENT HEARINGS OR
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE. THANK
YOU FOR CALLING IN THANK YOU
FOR OR- THE KNOWLEDGE OF
ANOTHER WORK THAT- THIS
COMMITTEE'S BEEN DOING AND
CERTAINLY THE WORK THAT- WE'VE
BEEN ADVOCATING FOR APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS. AND VERY WELL
RECEIVED AND TAKEN WITH THAT-
WE WILL LEAD THE FIRST HEARING
FOR THIS COMMITTEE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING THANK YOU
ALL AND- THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU THANK.
THANK YOU MR.